foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hey good morning everybody happy Friday
thank you guys so much for joining me
for this very very special live stream
and I'm not lying when I say this is a
very special one we have five artists
the top five winners from the most
recent 3D challenge
um we had thousands of artists enter
this challenge you guys worked so hard
to to to work for this thing you made
incredible art you guys saw it in the
top 100
in the all renders montage
and we're going to learn a bit about the
unique workflows and the unique
perspectives from artists all over the
world
um from these five artists today all
right so it's going to be very
informative it's going to be packed with
information with knowledge from
different programs
um different experiences different
workflows you guys are going to learn a
lot along the way for this one
um I'm very excited for it you know this
this is really what it comes down to
after these challenges is is learning as
much as we can from these artists so
I'm very excited for you guys it's good
to see you guys in the chat what's up
everybody thank you guys so much for
hopping in with us
um especially on a Friday on a Friday
morning you guys are you guys are
Troopers I really really appreciate it
um so
here's what we're gonna do all right
um we're gonna let people roll in here
we got some people rolling in and
whatnot and
um we're gonna hop into uh our first
artist Manuel who goes by roll jet on
Discord and we're gonna break down his
chameleon scene
um it's an incredible scene it's very
well lit very well rendered is all you
guys know all of these are very well lit
very well rendered
um but before we hop into it before we
get um to these artists uh I'm gonna
throw it to our sponsor
you guys know Rococo has been a huge
supporter of these challenges uh y'all
won suits throughout this
um they've given out gloves they're
always hooking y'all guys up with prizes
so
um shout outs to Rococo
so give it a couple minutes here
um we got a word from them and then
we're gonna hop right into it starting
with Manuel talking about his chameleon
scene all right so I'll see you guys in
just a second don't move them butts see
you soon today's boss fight winners
workflow live stream is brought to you
by Rococo who you know for the motion
capture suits they're smart gloves and
their facial capture technology now we
also know them for Rococo video the free
to use no suit needed browser based
motion capture solution but about one
month ago Rococo pushed the AI motion
capture game to the next level by
releasing the all-new dual camera
version of Rococo video called Rococo
Vision 2K
higher cash quality better depth
perception accurate ground floor
recognition and it also means no
occlusion since your lens will be
visible from at least one of those
cameras any two combos of cameras are
fair games so you can use a DSLR and a
phone or a phone in a webcam and you
sync them up with these printable QR
codes you can export your data straight
from the browser or use Rococo Studio to
make tweaks add characters and even make
retargeting adjustments which honestly
is huge because my goodness do I hate
retargeting now rococovision is part of
the Rococo plus service which means it's
240 bucks a year or 20 bucks a month
depending on how you break it down but
they do have a 14 day free trial I
linked it in the description down below
for you guys it's out right now you can
test it out but without further Ado
let's meet our boss fight 3D challenge
winners and learn all about their unique
workflows
hi I'm great how are you doing I'm great
dude yeah super solid these streams are
always the best man so thank you so much
for hopping in and I'm so excited to
take a look at your art man it's so so
beautiful I love it man
thank you thank you so a little bit
nervous but we'll we'll do this you know
all good
all good for me too there's always a
nervous excitement before I hop into
these things too you know we're live you
know so many so many things could go
wrong but no no this is just me and you
right now we're talking about the art
we're having a good time
um let me ask you man where are you from
uh how how old are you how long have you
been working in 3D
I'm based in Germany and I have around
10 years of experience in the 3D field
um and I'm 34 years ago amazing heck
yeah yeah
what got you into 3D what was the thing
that was like you know I think 3DS for
me I'm gonna start experimenting with
this
a friend of mine started using blender
and University and so this way I came up
with 3D software and write different
things
um I've been into art and growing and
things like that before and I was blown
away by the opportunity uh 3D software
gives you to create anything you can
imagine so
I I really was blown away in the first
place uh that a single person can
achieve such great things yeah it like I
think it's very good it's very similar
to what got me into it in the beginning
too was the idea that if you could think
it then you can create it and you're
basically only limited by your
of course we know technical ability
right but yeah that aside you're only
limited by your imagination and I
thought that was like so inspiring and I
think a lot of artists feel the same so
it's cool it's cool to hear you say that
um and and man you've come so so far
such a long way what were like the first
things that you that you experimented
with in 3D I'm sure
generally I I made still images for I
guess the first five years I didn't get
into anything animating yeah so I I just
modeled that stuff textured it and
rendered it but never came across really
to to animate things
so this began more when I when I started
to study a 3D design
for three and a half years uh at that
time I also started working with Cinema
4D but when I when I finished uh uh my
bachelor this is I I immediately turned
back to blender because it was it was my
software
um and I love the community that's also
part that kept me going with 3D
because there's so many people that want
to help you and can help you uh free to
share knowledge it's great yeah everyone
is on the same team it feels like
um yeah what did you feel like you
gained from using c4d for those three
and a half years and going back to
blender like obviously you didn't get
worse right but what did you take from
the C40 side that you could have then
apply using blender
generally after say Cinema 40 has
awesome uh motion graphic tools and back
at that time blender didn't have
anything comparable to it and and that
was uh so so there was also some
modeling techniques I learned in cinema
that I adapted and then I started using
in blender
um that I didn't know of before so they
were uh certain things I could I could
get to blender
super important it doesn't matter like
what part of your journey you're on
you're always learning something and
applying it to your future self so
that's cool to hear
um also all the after effects stuff I
learned at this time so basically to
comp and do Motion Graphics
that's great
yeah I want to ask you about your scene
here so
what what inspired this idea how did you
come up with this idea of course when we
launched the challenge you you know it's
boss fight it's David versus Goliath
like how did you come up with this idea
as opposed to anything else
first off I I didn't think that I would
participate because I'm not really a
character animation guy I'm more into
as as I did in my early years more
interesting images more into shading and
texturing and things like that making
beautiful visuals but not into rigging
waiting weight painting and stuff like
that and it's like hard stuff so and
it's all different stuff it's it's the
really difficult stuff so so
I I thought twice about participating
but then I I said to myself let's try it
let's push it and and see what we can
achieve and that way if I thought about
what could I do and I'm
generally natural
keeps inspiring me so I thought about
making some some creature and I I just
went online and looked for references
and a friend of mine
um at that point I also stopped usually
and and making a board where I just
throwing in some references and stuff
like that yeah and I came up with the
idea of a chameleon
um attacking a fly and I saw two
wonderful CGI animations uh one by
Thomas where chameleon
catches different uh different insects
and the insects keep getting bigger and
bigger and the chameleon can really do
it in the end and another one was this
one with a more stylized but also very
cute looking chameleon it's called Uh
short films called Pascal
on in the Daryl sorry
um and these two films were so funny in
my mind and I I thought let's try a
mixture of both of them
um a little stylized character that
isn't really super hyper realistic and
combine it with a pixel-like surfaces
and shading that looks realistic and
that way I I ended up with this idea and
um yeah then I I started just doing a
first block out uh I had a lizard made
that I made some years ago that was the
base mesh I started to sculpt a little
bit and do it uh and you can see this
was the the first uh
a smash of the chameleon so really low
poly
um nothing fancy here and I um
everything mirrored and uh this stuff I
put into your tablet scene and looked
and this work
um the sidewall the sizes work and look
which template of the three you you gave
um would be the best
after
um just just to hit your point on that
so there were three starter files there
was a close medium and far depending on
you know the kind of scene you wanted to
create so I think it looks it looks to
me here you went with the close the
close-ups yeah exactly
um because it was such a narrow scene
and I wanted to to have a really
impactful attack on the fly so I I went
with a with a small distance between the
two characters and after that I I didn't
really go for a straightforward pipeline
uh because I thought to myself when I'm
not able to to achieve the lighting and
the surfaces and the look of the whole
thing to look the way I want it to look
I I want start animating and stuff and
and do secondary animation stuff when
I'm not um
super sure that I can pull out something
cool and something beautiful so at this
point I also started and started some
shading tests and things like that and
um
you can have a photo here that was a
render I took about a week after I
started the project so the the the
geometry of the the chameleon is still
really low poly it's more at shading but
uh sells the story and sells the realism
so I started with this when I saw the
image and I saw okay this could lead me
to something
um
I was even more ambitious and started
working more time on it and and started
with the other stuff so then I thought
about the the fly
um lies basically
um hold on I'm gonna stop you here I'm
gonna stop you here okay because
I I think what you just said is very
important and I want to highlight that
and I think it's something that I could
even take advice from because go back to
that image that you had yeah
so
I find myself
needing
reassurance
that what I'm making is gonna work
and it's gonna be cool and I think
that's what I love so much about
texturing in 3D is that it was a pretty
quick payoff
um especially using like a hdri to light
your scene
hitting render and having a nice texture
with some surface imperfections it just
looks so good so quickly and that gives
me the Boost that I need to continue
going forward on this big Journey right
whether it be
um you know the project you're working
on in this case yes the project you're
working on so what you did here is you
actually put together an almost
like I guess would you consider this
like a style frame or something right uh
it's a pretty clean looking version of
what you're going to create and when you
can prove to yourself that oh that it's
looking nice close-up kind of close-up
to the beginning then you can deal with
the more difficult stuff a little bit
later and give yourself the reassurance
that it's working it's working right
yeah yeah that's exactly what I also
needed and and this is also the the time
when I I shared it to other people
and and said hey have a look at it how
does it look can that work and uh this
is the time when I also felt the first
time enough confident that I I know
Andrew would would get good if I have
I'm
it was an important step and therefore
the tongue nothing is animated here it's
just a real image but it goes to me that
I that it can get really great yeah I
think in my art
um for the challenge which I honestly
wasn't able to finish
I think I was missing this step
I I think personally I could have used a
final look
step early on and I think for me I was
like searching for that look for the
entire process and I was never quite
happy with the look and it took so long
to get to a point where
this stylized look felt right and it
never quite did and I think it was just
a marathon that I wasn't able to finish
I think having having something like
this at the beginning of the project
would have really helped so it's it
really pushes your confidence yes yeah
yeah that's very true man that's very
true Okay so
the fly all right so tell me about this
the fly is isn't that that crazy
um basically
a billion for one second
it's just a humanoid character I took
and I edited
anymore a little smile and now I added
some tentacles uh on the head and a
little mouth coming out and I did wings
and stuff like that and this is nothing
like yeah nothing nothing fancy here
um
when I started animating it I I did some
ambient animations with the tentacles
here moving around and the mouth kind of
tubing
um at this point I also want to mention
that the Discord servers really
oftentimes a great help I had
I've ripped threads uh where I showed my
progress and at one time one guy said
hey let's do a blinking animation that
would make everything even more natural
and I haven't really thought about this
at the beginning but then I thought yeah
every great CGI animation has kind of
blinking so I tried it and adopted this
so great shout out here to the to the
server and the guys helping out there
um yeah that's good to hear me it's cool
yeah that's nice yeah and basically it's
just an ik rig with hands and and
nothing too crazy
erector's Roofing around uh on the spine
I think too crazy here okay so you
modeled your chameleon it looks like you
got uh something for the tongue and then
you modeled the fly character so once
you had kind of a bass uh environment
which we clearly saw from that image you
just showed you have the main characters
like what's what's next for you do you
continue building out the environment do
you start animating
um where where does where do you want to
go from here from here
um I I had the benefit that I already
made parts of the environment for the
still frame and I knew okay these assets
will be static most of them the rocks
and stuff like that and they're also
there I got most of the assets online
from polyhaven from a great site I want
to mention uh
for me the best site for each year I is
by by far and also a growing library of
textures and bottles and also photo
scanned Cliffs so I I took some stuff
from them it's all free too right it's
every even for a commercial use that's
click so that that was a great thing so
the environment is mostly from
that I that I had um another thing that
I wanted to mention is uh the tongue
because the tongue gave me headaches but
at the first I I wanted the the fly to
to not
make a knot in in the tongue but
in 120 frames it wasn't possible to to
show that much motion and yeah
um so I decided to to let the fly wrap
it around and I thought how can I
technically do this thing so this is a
little hack I made and I wanted to share
um it's basically a cloth Sim
flat cloth that the ends are pinned to
an empty to a null object
um let me go to start the cloth Sim and
and it's hooked to this empties and
these empties are animated to move
around an obstacle
and basically that's the base of the
Chong animation Plus in the flat surface
and after that after as as usual when
when when simulating stuff you have to
do it try an error style and and have a
lot of iterations but then finally I had
one
um I exported this as an alembic file
and put it in my file then gave it some
thickness to it
and displaced it that's basically uh how
I made the tongue and uh can I can can
we see like the final final version of
uh of your render yeah I might be I can
switch on to rendered view here
I think it won't crash hopefully but
I can also show yeah this works this way
your friend here so okay success
extruded displacement
um displacement then I duplicate it the
whole tongue and uh gave the
displacement a slide off that with
another noise texture and this gave
another Shader with more translucency to
have that kind of gooey liquidy feel
around it so dude that's so good two
types of material on that is so nice
and uh it's a lot of subsurface
scattering that that tells the story I
guess so
a nice little way of of tricking how to
to achieve something like that and
basically as you can see here um
it's really going just going through the
mouth it's not connected to the main
body it's it's with a gradient texture
faded out and it it gets out of the
mouth
and because the mouth is so so dark you
can't really tell that it's not
connected so it's it's a lot of hacky
stuff that I did but at the end you
can't see most of the hacky stuff so
it's working yeah I love it you cheated
man you just cheat it and until it works
it doesn't have to be perfect how did
you do go back to your final render
how did you do the saliva the corners of
the mouth
Ah that's basically a duplicate of the
the mouth topology so I I just took a
you mean this uh yeah yeah yeah it's
it's a duplicate of the Interior part of
the mouth
so it was also connected to the to the
Armature to the the bones and um after
that I deleted them I connected both
sides of the mouth and deleted a lot of
faces and just kept the single strands
connecting the top and the bottom and it
gave them a weekly displacement that I
could animate in time so it wiggles at
the end when it's hit by the stick
so that's
another hack I guess it's it's not
really that complicated and also with a
solidify a thickness given to it
yes dude it works so it's not simmed
it's just
yeah it's not same I can maybe I can
show you so good
um
you it's uh quite
quite heavy on the machine so
hopefully oh yeah here you can see the
mesh
basically part of the mouth that is also
connected to the bones
got it okay
amazing okay all right so I have I have
so many questions I'll continue to ask
them but yeah um
you got your tongue figured out okay you
have the fly animated around this thing
um at what point did the like the stick
going into the chameleon's mouth come
about was that always something that you
wanted to do from the beginning or did
you discover that through just creating
that was something I wanted to do I
wasn't sure if I can pull it off in the
120 frames yeah because of the slo-mo I
also had to integrate into the scene and
therefore I wasn't that sure but I
wanted it to to have that special uh
which at the end
um and even can can the chameleon
switches colors so I have that that gag
at the end
man I'm not gonna say that's what
topped it off for me
um
but honestly it kind of did because if
it was just looping around and the Fly
flew away like it would have been nice
you know but dude that retaliation that
counter move
that that really took it to the next
level because a lot of the renders you
know the majority of the renders
that we saw it was just a Face-Off you
know just two people static
um and then
a lot of the renders also had a thing
where like the artist would just do the
cool thing
right at the end like they would slow-mo
the wrong part they wouldn't slow-mo the
explosion they would slow-mo like uh the
wand casting a spell and the explosion
happened at the end it's like no I want
to see the explosion in slow motion yeah
yeah but like
you had an A and A B and A C going on
with this like we're setting up even the
top with the other fly distracting him
right like flying and hitting the eye
there's so much going on
and that was also a tip from another
Discord user with a distracting flyer
okay
uh if I don't know his username but he
said hey the the comedian looks to the
left side that strong at the at the
beginning
uh where where is it looking and that
that was the the reason why I put it in
the the second fly flying to the left
side so another shout out here that's
crazy guys there and it extends the
eyeball too how did you do that how did
you like animate the eyeball bulging
like this
as I said earlier the the rig of the
chameleon is really basic it's just uh I
guess 20 bones and a simple animating
but I kept more focus on pose Morse and
blender they are called shape keys to
make a little smile to make the eye
bulge out
um to to uh sneeze so also the the
impact basically that that's happening
at the end is also just a shape key that
I that I sculpted in and then could
could animate the slider that this was
isn't a bone animation it's just shape
keys so this way this way it was much
easier for me to animate as I said I'm
not really the greatest animator so I I
also cheated with this stuff and uh also
the eyeballs the eyeballs got a separate
Bones on each side two bones for each
eye so I could uh literally just go in
and
um take the Armature and it just scale
up the the bone of the eye to get that
effect to that scaling effect
yeah and and even to scale it just in
one dimension or
this is the right one I guess as
basically that's just that just a little
scale animation on the bone can you do
all of us a favor please can you just
select both of those eyeballs and like
bulge them up to the max I just I just
want to see that real quick
uh let me switch the
oh
like that
oh gotten a bit too far
it's like uh you know Arnold
Schwarzenegger and um
whatever that movie was I forget
yeah good times very good time so
basically
um
that's uh that was one point and another
point I I wanted to to show is the
secondary animation I did uh with the
spines here yeah um tell me about
secondary animation why is it important
because it tells the story I guess you
you shouldn't overdo it it shouldn't be
stronger than the the real animation but
it adds a lot of realism and it's
yeah it's it's the characters come alive
when you add secondary animations like
that I guess even though I'm not that
great of an animator but uh
no well I think also this works in in uh
in this they are they are not that
extremely visible but when you when you
look at them
it has this fishy kind of uh look to it
um and that tells the story so this is
an add-on blender called Spring bones
which lets you animate that you you
basically just animate the bass phone
and everything else it Wiggles
dynamically so you don't have to animate
anything
besides the the first phone the rest
keeps wiggling like like a physic
simulation basically oh that's really
really handy
shoot okay that's great
um any other okay so we have we have a
handful of minutes left
um
do you have
any other well let me let me ask you
this let me see this what was the most
difficult part of this project for you
what was like the biggest hurdle
keep going with the animation stuff
because I'm not that good at that and
that's also when when uh feedback is
very important to get feedback on your
on your animations and I had colleagues
watching the the animation and said I uh
the chameleon should lean back what's
when it's hit by the by the stick and
things like that
um because you sometimes use you get
don't have a you need a fresh eye on it
and this helps sometimes so that was the
the trickiest part I guess because
shading and lighting and things like
that I'm comfortable with so that's not
the problem it's more the the movement
and and the speed of movement and things
like that that
were hard for me yeah I see okay um hey
guys in the chat we have a handful of
minutes left with Manuel
um hit me with an at Punisher if you
have questions for him
um hopefully the ad Punisher just makes
a little easier for us to see your
questions in the chat but
um I want to get your guys's
questions in here while we still have a
little bit of time I'll check back with
you all in a second
um but man well what would you say to to
artists who
are afraid
to enter these challenges who feel like
ah the artists you have nothing to lose
basically
um the community is great you you can
learn and you don't have to make it to
the top 100 the first time but you you
can get great feedback on your work and
it's a lot of fun and there's nothing to
lose so uh
if you're
fun doing this kind of stuff try it
don't be afraid of it
um I think that's great I have one last
scene open that I wanted to show let's
do it because this this was a difficult
part
um to incorporate the slow motion part
and because I had a particle simulation
I had clocked simulation I had rigid
body simulations I had shape keys and
animated bones and therefore I would
have hundreds of keyframes to adapt to
really slow down my whole scene because
I would have to to put a hand on every
single keyframe so basically what I did
I exported the whole scene as an alembic
file yeah and the nice thing is to
re-import the alembic file you have this
slider it's called override frame it
basically tells us which time in the
scene it's showing at the moment so at
the end I had my whole scene in another
scene and I had one single F curve
controlling the whole time of the scene
so basically this is the the time of the
scene and I also I could even go reverse
in time uh I I can let it go exactly at
the same time I did it was before but I
can also keep it still
um or even Go reverse when I play this
and this works with everything I did
with particle simulation with cloth
simulation and everything so I had the
total freedom to to start the slow
motion effect right when I wanted it and
let it go exactly when I what needed it
to that's perfect that's perfect man wow
that was so it actually did it Lifesaver
for me did it bring in your
your foliage like everything it brought
in the whole scene yeah yeah basically
everything that was animated so the
grass was animated and bended uh the
leaves were falling and and moved in the
wind uh basically everything the the the
mouth the tongue everything besides the
rock basically the Rocks weren't moving
so these were imported separately but
everything else was imported with an
alembic and overwritten here and the the
Olympic is even capable of vertex
interpolation so um you you can have sub
steps in between the frames and even
have no problems wow okay so this was a
really great way
yeah you converted all of your
hundreds of keyframes into one keyframe
essentially by exports and controlling
the speed that's so good that's so good
um that's that's a great takeaway so
let's let's take a look at chat here you
guys had some questions for Manuel
let's see
um of these questions what would you
have done as a second option what made
you think of using empties for so much
of the project
um system specs
um can you do the tongue from scratch
probably not we don't have time for that
um any of these stand out to you
um maybe we'll start with what made you
think of using null objects so much to
animate with
it's basically a lifesaver when whenever
I start animating and and moving around
things it gets more complicated when you
move the object itself so I I generally
I put everything in empties and uh so
the class the Sim the the the points are
parented to an empty that is controlled
other characters are apparented to
empties the tongues a separated parent
to empty so basically if I can't really
think of a workflow where I don't use
empties so it's just like easier to
control basically yeah yeah
that's a that's that's great yeah that
sounds pretty basic but honestly I'm
like every time I'm like oh how do I
animate it's getting complicated like I
want to do X and Y and Z and animate
them all separate it's like just
different different null objects it's
like a great answer awesome
also for for things like camera movement
and animation yes another objects are
really great
uh let's see let's see
um all right what system are you working
on and how much time did all of this
take you
uh I'm working with Windows 10 and I
have uh two 30 90 graphic cards for
rendering so
I think all the project took me about
working time about 70 to 80 hours I
guess
um render time was one night I guess 10
hours maybe cool
yeah amazing man amazing how how close
did you push it uh to submitting what
did you submit on the last day did you
submit no no no I submitted uh three
days before before okay solid solid yeah
there's definitely a bell curve of like
of yeah of all that stuff so it's good
three days before solid I like that but
um man I think that's about all the time
we have for Manuel thank you so much
um for well congratulations first off uh
for winning thanks and uh third place
yeah and
and man seriously thank you for having
me it was really a pleasure yeah
Abby like please come by next year
and uh thanks for being on the Discord
server and inspiring the community with
your art and um being so helpful and
open and and uh just being solid on the
Discord man that's super cool
um I wish you the best thank you for
staying up late uh over in Germany for
this I really appreciate it and please
don't be a stranger okay
yeah is there anything that you want to
say to the chat before you bounce or uh
are you feeling good like job well done
here
yeah I think uh one thing is come to the
Discord server there's a lot of great
stuff there people are really helpful
amazing amazing yeah uh which there is a
link by the way for you guys down in the
description below if you want to do that
um all right Manuel we'll let you go
brother see you great one I'll catch you
catch you soon all right
all right later man
ah super solid super solid it's so good
I love it we're in it we're uh you know
chatting about all the good art so next
up we have an artist
um I believe is Robin is next our fifth
place
artist and he is on vacation he was not
able to join us live today but he
recorded an incredible breakdown for you
guys um it's packed with detail
um you know I watched it a couple times
it's so good so informative and I know
that you guys are gonna get a bunch from
it it's a very different kind of
approach all these what I love about all
this by the way is that all five of
these artists they do similar things but
they have completely different workflows
different
um different Specialties different tips
and tricks to offer you guys so there's
something to learn from every single one
of these we just finished our first one
Manuel and we're hopping in we got four
more to do
um I'm gonna throw it to Robin he's
gonna
take on uh take you guys on a journey
here so kick back grab a drink grab a
snack and uh let's get ready to learn
some cool stuff
uh we'll throw it to you Robin go for it
hi everyone I'm Robin pitalco I'm from
Germany and I'm the creator of the Tomb
Raider theme video
even though I'm writing my master thesis
right now I still decided to take part
in this challenge because I finally
wanted to submit something I tried to
participate in the previous challenges
but I always give up and that's because
I said unrealistic goals for myself
sometimes my PC couldn't even handle it
anymore so this time I decided to pull
through no matter what I promised myself
to finish it and to submit it and this
is exactly what I did and this is why it
makes me even more proud to
um to got the fifth place right away so
thank you very much again
now before we start I wanted to say
sorry that I can't be there for the live
stream but when the live stream takes
place I'm unfortunately not at home so
this is why I'm recording some material
for you now and I hope you find it
interesting and if you have any question
you can always write me on Discord so
yeah let's start
immediately after seeing Glenn's
announcement video for whatever reason I
had an image of a Tampa scene in my head
I wanted to do something with some kind
of Mayan God in the middle of the jungle
I also thought about the bosses of Far
Cry 3 and Shadow of the Tomb Raider so I
knew relatively quickly what my scene
would involve
but I had no exact image in my head so I
decided to just start with something I
knew I wanted to have in my scene I
searched for a few images from the
internet and put them together to make a
reference board at that time you could
already try out the new stable diffusion
model sdxl on a website so I typed in
terms like Maya Warrior or God or a
cinematic jungle scene just to gather
inspiration for the look of my scene
from each of the pictures you see here I
took an idea and put it into my scene
especially for the design of the boss
this picture here is especially
responsible for how my scene looks now
for example the orange trees the orange
volumetric glow the rocks in the
foreground and the moon after I gathered
enough pictures I had a pretty exact
image in my mind how I wanted it to look
like but I didn't know what I wanted to
happen in the scene all I knew was that
I wanted the boss to attack in some form
with the hero evading in a cool way
maybe it would have been better if I
decided on that early on but in that
case it thankfully worked to figure it
out while building the scene
before I started building the scene I
was looking for assets the first time I
decided not to do everything myself so
that it's enough time to finish by the
end of the month I was looking for
temple assets because they would be a
big part of my scene and this is what I
found
I added the assets to my file and tried
to build a basic scene I changed the
ground a bit added the sidewalls and
positioned the temple
I also added placeholders for the rocks
and the vines in the foreground
after the basic scene was done I used
the botanic asset library to add some
plants I especially wanted to see how
the orange trees would look like in My
Scene I added more plants like palm
trees bushes grass and Ivy to give the
scene an overgrown look
for the grass I quickly created a
geometry node system that lets me draw
grass onto the ground that way I had
very easy control over where the grass
is growing
for this guy I used some pictures I
found online to use as a texture on a
plane since I could not find any fitting
hdris
the same thing goes for the moon I
wanted it to be very moody and cloudy
with the big round moon shining through
now since the camera is going in a
circular motion from left to right I had
to fill in the sky on both sides by
adding half of a cylinder with another
Sky texture on it I then blended it into
the plane with the main Sky texture
using a gradient texture
the next thing I did was adding lights
to see how I could best light the scene
together look similar to the AI images
so I added a blue colored sun lamp as
Moonlight I also added a large
rectangular light for the right side of
the temple to enhance the Moonlight in
specific places
this is not really realistic I know but
I thought it looks better that way
then I added a point lamp to each of the
places where the firewood later burn on
the columns I added an orange rectangle
light in the middle of the scene which
would later be responsible for the edge
lighting of the characters
I used the default boss fight figures to
see how the light might look in the end
as in the reference images I wanted the
blue light from the night sky to shine
as indirect Lighting on the characters
that's why I also added two blue
rectangle lights above the boss and the
hero even though I added a volume to get
some fork in my scene I was missing the
Big Orange volumetric effect I saw in
the reference pictures that's why I
decided to fake it by using a circular
gradient texture on a plane and scale it
up until it looks like fog that gets
illuminated by some orange light
also while I was building the foreground
I always kept the composition in mind
for example I wanted to create a natural
vignette by positioning and lighting the
plants Temple assets and rocks in such a
way that the scene appears a bit darker
towards the edge of the image after I
was happy with the basic scene I started
to replace all the placeholders for the
plants Vines rocks and so on
I quickly added some skeletons lying
around using an asset I found online and
now the basic scene was done all I had
to do now was adding the characters and
adding some details and effects I asked
myself what the next most important
thing is I need to take care of I chose
the boss because the viewer will be
looking primarily at him
I started with a muscular male base
model however the proportions were not
quite as I imagined the boss therefore I
shortened his legs and made him much
wider at the shoulder
since I didn't know what exactly his
armor should look like I just started
with the face I wanted his face to
resemble one of those Mayan wooden masks
since I couldn't find a mask I liked on
Google I had sdx I'll have me again
after making the image of the Mask
symmetrical I roughly modeled the mask
and used the image as a texture which
gave the mask the details
after that I started modeling the body
armor to be honest I had no structure
here I just started with a breastplate
and added more and more parts until I
was satisfied with the armor
since the armor in the reference images
had some kind of structure I downloaded
a tribal pattern and used it as a height
map and color mix also the metalness was
controlled with this
with noise textures I created an old
somewhat dirty look and introduced
irregularities into the material most of
the parts then got a metal Edge
here and there I looked at the reference
pictures every now and then as to what
constitutes tribal armor for example
from this picture I have the belt thing
with the round part in the front
and from these pictures I took the idea
of the crown with the metal feathers I
added a few details here and there and
then the boss design was finished
I then downloaded a spear model and
adapted the style and colors to my
character
all I had to do now was to rig the
character I did this with rigify and
then added some extra bones to be able
to animate the armor later
after the boss was finished I downloaded
a Lara Croft model from the internet I
found this asset since this character
was already rigged all I had to do was
to adjust the materials and make it a
bit more realistic
the next most important step was the
animation at this point I still didn't
quite know how their characters should
move so I looked through the animations
at mcsamo and found this animation I
thought this animation would be perfect
for this beer so all I had to do was
find an animation that would allow Lara
to Dodge in a cool way
and this is what I found since Lara
needed something to prop herself up for
this move I decided to use a stone from
the ruin
from that second on I could picture Lara
spinning in slow-mo over the spear as
it's smashing the stone into a thousand
pieces I downloaded the animations and
retargeted both characters
since the animations didn't fit
perfectly yet I adjusted both for
example I changed the angle at which the
boss swings the spear I also had to
adjust the head movement because I
didn't want the boss to lose focus on
Lara I did the same with Lara so that
she looks at the boss before and after
the flip now the basic animation was
there after that I took care of the
secondary animations like the finger
position Lara's hair and the individual
armor pieces of the boss
all these things I animated by hand
which took me a lot of time because I'm
not an animator I understand the basic
principles of animating mass and gravity
but I have to admit that I animated the
individual pieces of armor and Lara's
hair only through trial and error
after playing around with the animation
for several hours I was finally
satisfied with it
finally I added corrective shape Keys
here and there and made corrections to
the animation
now it was finally time for all the
effects and to make the scene look more
epic I started with the rigid body
simulation of the stone first I split
the stone into many small pieces using
cell fracture
I could then Collide these with a spear
causing the individual pieces to fly
across the scene
however the breaking of the stone still
looked very boring as all the details
were missing I added a particle system
that spawns many small stones as soon as
the spear hits the stone
I tried to match the speed and direction
to the rigid body simulation I then
repeated the same process with the
skeleton I placed in front of the Stone
now finally came the part I had been
looking forward to All Along The
simulation of the dust cloud when the
spear shatters the stone
for this I used ambigen of course I
imported the rigid body simulation that
I had previously converted to keyframes
as well as some scene objects that would
surface colitis for the smoke for
example the spear the wall the floor and
some rocks the rigid body simulation
served as their emitter for the smoke I
played around with the settings for a
long time until the smoke looked like
dust from the shadowed Stone all I had
to do then was to save the smoke as a
VDB sequence and paste it into blender
I also created a second dust simulation
that represents the dust kicked up from
this beard I basically use the exact
same steps only this time I animated a
flat object along the ground and use it
as an emitter in ambigen now it was
impossible to play the animation in real
time because the real part became very
slow after pressing the play button
I also used the object I animated along
the ground to swirl some grass in the
air for this I used a simple particle
system with high air resistance
again I started ambogen to render out
fire texture sequences for the fire on
the columns in the background
for this I used the default Amazon fire
with slightly changed values I imported
the sequence as a texture on a plane and
made sure that they were always oriented
towards the camera
I then offset the sequence per plane so
that the fire does move in the same way
using geometry notes I created a
particle system for fireflies flying
around in the scene I then made them
blink in the Shadow using a sine wave
as a last step I wanted to add birds
flying across the sky using a video on a
plane after moving one or two things
around I decided that I was happy with
my scene and called it done
since I was already pretty happy with
the rendered scene I didn't have to do a
lot of compositing for that I used
blender exclusively I added glare
filters for a foglow effect and adjusted
the colors a bit although I had already
created a natural vignette I still added
a conventional vignette and chromatic
aberration this way the render got the
final cinematic look
when I added the smoke my render slowed
down quite a bit that's why I wanted to
render the animation with a random fun
however you can only send it to a render
Farm if you put all the external data
like textures cache files and VDB
sequences in a relative folder structure
including the blend file it took me
quite a while to set up this photo but
when I finally did I then uploaded the
folder to the render farm and rendered
out the final animation
alright that's basically it I've learned
quite a few things especially about my
own workflow and now I want to share
with you guys my four key takeaways
beginning with setting yourself some
realistic goals so think about what you
can do and think about what you can do
think about the time that you have left
this is very important the second thing
is use assets there's absolutely no
shame in using assets for the longest
time I thought using assets made by
other people will make the project that
I'm currently working on not really my
project anymore
um the third point is
at the most important stuff first to
your scene you can always refine it
later if you don't do that there's a
good chance that your motivation will
leave you just because you don't see any
progress
and the last point is if your PC can't
handle the rendering
think about using a render Farm it can
be expensive at times yes but where's
the point in spending in my case 50 plus
hours on a project without ever having
some kind of output that you can be
proud of
so yeah this is my project I hope you
found it interesting and I hope you're
motivated for the next challenge so have
fun bye
heck yeah thank you Robin I'm sad that
we couldn't have you live here but dude
that's a complete breakdown thank you so
much for putting that together
um I know you guys appreciated that I
hope you enjoyed it I I know you enjoyed
it let's get real
um so for any of you guys wanting to
follow any of these artists today on the
stream I got all their info linked below
for you
um and later when I go through and do
the time codes for the video I'll have
it all separated by the artist so you
guys can come back here this video uh
will be on the channel forever so uh if
if you need to bounce out or if you're
just bouncing in then uh we'll have the
full video for you guys to come back too
later so
we are going to move on to our third
artist this guy got let me see if I do
this right fourth place
um let's uh let's let's meet him let's
hop on over
thank you for the switch we did it yes
what's up
what's going on man how are you how are
you thanks for having me man yeah
absolutely absolutely I'm gonna get
myself a little brightness if you're
looking good by the way I gotta say what
do you got a soft box going I do yep
soft box up above yeah oh man so crisp I
need that little soft box action over
here you got the background lights gone
dude yeah you're looking clean yeah
appreciate it so yeah at one point I was
gonna do some like YouTube streaming and
stuff but
it's all good
um all right so we have a lot to hop
into
um first off I wanna say that you have
been on the Discord server participating
in these weekly challenges for how long
now
um it's probably been around a little
over two years I think my very first uh
real introduction on the Discord and
stuff was Dynamic machines I wanted to
try to participate in that one yeah I
think that was challenge just such a
three I believe this is challenge seven
which is insane how many of these
challenges have you done
um since then
um so I've done pretty much all of the
big Community challenges since then and
I don't remember what I was up to on the
weeklies I think something like 40 or
something like that uh the the bot
unfortunately has been down for a little
while but yeah
um I'm on a pretty long streak I'd just
like to
those weekly challenges keep me fresh
just trying to come up with new ideas
and different things to do
um and the prompts you know even if it's
a prompt that I don't like it's like
well what can I do how can I interpret
this my way and what can I use to make
it so yeah yeah and I think it really
pays off so for the for those of you
guys who don't know I'm sure most of you
do but on the Discord server we host the
weekly challenges it's very similar to
like inktober if you're um an
illustrator where you get a prompt every
day for the month of October but in this
case on the Discord server you get a
prompt once a week
um every week basically except when
we're doing these big Community
challenges and it's just a way to keep
the challenges going uh keep pushing
yourself and metatrox here has been
doing them for about two years he has
one of the longest streaks on the server
um and like you've been at it for a
while and I remember when you started
your art was you know it was good but
like it you win them pretty regularly at
this point and it's really impressive to
see you continue to do this like a lot
of people would be like ah I'm gonna
move on I'm not gonna do the weeklies
anymore I'm just going to focus on the
bigger stuff but you come back every
time like why why do you keep coming
back every week
um like I said uh primarily I would say
it just it's something that keeps me
fresh keeps me moving you know we all
have life and other things that kind of
distract us or other projects but I
think spending a day or two or you know
at least a few hours on some of these a
week I think just uh
kind of helps ignite a little something
in there you know for me personally a
lot of times when I'm working on a
project if it gets drug out really long
I kind of get bored with it and I know
it's probably hard to you know not the
right thing to say but I I just get
bored with it and it's like okay so
every week I know I have at least one
fresh new thing that more or less I'm
gonna practice my skills learn something
different it's more of like a personal
project or a passion project which most
of us like those you know so that's
probably the main reason why I just kind
of keep doing them it's fun yeah man
absolutely and and I just gotta commend
your
um your persistence because you you've
been doing these 3D challenges for for a
while the the the big ones the 3D
Community challenges the month-long ones
and I'm just so happy for you that you
that you won on this one man it's so
cool your art let's talk about the art
this is unbelievable it's so good it's
so so good thank you um there's so much
going on I have so many questions
questions about everything I'm seeing
here but let's Pace ourselves and let's
begin with the first question
how did you get this idea where did this
come from
so initially
um when you first released a video you
know I started kind of trying to figure
out what what do I want to do what type
of style what type of type of theme
um and so most most people in the
community probably know me I I used a
lot of assets and so a lot of times
instead of using necessarily like
references or mid-journey or something
AI to kind of give me inspiration
sometimes a lot of the assets that I
have or assets that I see kind of give
me a little bit of my inspiration
and so initially I wanted I had two
ideas it was either
go sci-fi or I kind of wanted to do
maybe something along the lines of like
um
Lord of the Rings like a big giant orc
and maybe have the hero battling some
some smaller trolls or something or
something like that or vice versa and
then
do something of that sort but you know
as I started to kind of look for assets
and things of that sort you know there
was stuff out there but not quite what I
felt would fit what I wanted to do down
that route
um and I'm a big fan of sci-fi I really
like a lot of sci-fi stuff I do a lot of
sci-fi work
and I knew I already had some assets
that I think would work well that I
could incorporate well together and so
that's kind of what gave me the first
initial idea
okay got it so you had like your tool
set and your workbench was your
inspiration in this case
um correct you're like here's here's
what I have to work with
um and here are the things that I can
pull quickly and you start making the
making something from what you already
have so where do you begin like what's
your process when you first start out
how do you start playing with these
assets that you have
so um of course I use Unreal Engine so
what's really nice about unreal is that
you can just get the basically the full
quality asset in there see what it's
going to look like start to light things
a little bit and you get a really good
representation right away uh like you
were talking with manuals like you kind
of wanted that step of a little bit of
payoff where like I'm doing all this
technical stuff ahead of time that it
takes so long to get that visual payoff
and I think that's one thing that's
really nice about unreal and especially
using assets it's like I already know
what this is basically going to look
like you know I'm gonna make texture
changes and material changes and I'm
going to relight stuff but I can drop an
asset in it and choose some animations
and be like wow okay this is already a
thing within literally a few days you
know I already had my basic boss
animation and hero animation like I knew
those were two things that I wanted
right away was
um I wanted the boss to be doing some
sort of impact and I wasn't sure what
that was
um right away but I knew I wanted to use
that slow motion as some sort of impact
in the scene whether it be explosion or
something of that sort and so
um uh fortunately the character the boss
that I used was a free Paragon character
that literally comes on the unreal
Marketplace and
um I he has some pre-made animations so
I went in those made some tweaks to how
I wanted to like it a little bit of the
timing changes
um because I as you can see I didn't
want both
um chains to hit the floor exactly the
same time so I offset them a little bit
so I could have two different explosions
you know a very slight offset there
um and then once I get the the
characters in there and the general
motion
um now it comes down to
how do I incorporate an environment
around this and how do I include that
environment into the action that's
happening
okay okay do you have one of your early
like what's your earliest render I do
um so my earliest render which this is
one of the the pros and negatives of
using Unreal since you get to see
everything in real time uh you don't
really do renders early on
um because you see it you don't have to
render stuff out yes um so this would be
probably one of my earliest renders
unfortunately it already has got a lot
going on
um not a ton uh so
like I said I got the boss in the hero
animations and then I just started to
move some objects in okay why is the
hero going to be leaping are they just
leaping away from the explosion or what
so I added a barrier there and started
to add some simple props
um you know a lot of the assets that I
use
um I use there's tons of free stuff out
there and mega scans the whole ground is
all Mega scans and qixel and a few other
things in there all you know the the
main barrier the sandbags it's all just
Mega scans you know
um one tip that I always like to use is
don't use the stock textures or at least
modify them color tint them change them
do something so that it's not as
noticeable yeah
um yeah
um and then I just started to add
um some buildings
um I had some kit bash 3D environment
buildings that I recently picked up that
had launched and you know uh one thing I
always tell people I know a lot of the
some of the assets I have are paid and
expensive but I don't just buy them
just to buy them or buy them for a
challenge like there's always sales 50
off 70 off and I understand that not
everybody is able to buy assets or spend
money in but there is a lot of free
stuff out there
so anyways I had recently picked up the
kit bash 3D and I just started kind of
drop in some of those elements because I
wanted to start getting an idea of The
Parallax that was actually happening
because okay so you you have you had the
the two characters the boss the hero you
had the animations figured out then you
started to bring in some of the
environment to justify why this person
was dive rolling over something right
um correct and you kind of had your
foreground figured out a little bit and
at this point you're like okay well
let's let's figure out what the
background looks like especially with
the camera move to get a better sense of
your overall scene so you started
pulling kit bash assets is that what
we're looking at here are these these
sci-fi buildings on the left and right
correct yeah the left and right and a
couple of the props are all part of like
bash 3D um the mountains and stuff in
the background that's just Mega scan
stuff
um and then I had some other robotic or
sci-fi characters that I had in my
library and so I just started to bring
them in and try to color tone them and
match them so that they all felt to be
as a of a team yes and I originally
started with like yellow which I kind of
I liked it because it seemed to pop off
the screen but eventually I wanted to
change the colors because I knew I
wanted to separate the hero or the good
guys from the bad guys using color
palette
um so I'll switch over here to this next
the next section here so I started to oh
well actually in the initial render here
I also have
um my vdbs so
um yeah how because that's the biggest
question is like how are you getting
that integrated
so this was the first time I really
started with VDB stuff in unreal um I
was using 5.2 which requires a plug-in
and uh it was so awesome that ember gin
kind of gave that free month uh during
the challenge it worked perfectly it was
a great way to get into it yeah so I
started with basic yeah I started with
the presets and started to make some
tweaks to what I knew you know the to
fine tune it the way I wanted it to be
um and speaking of like the the slow
motion aspect
um I had a lot of people ask what I
ended up doing was taking the explosions
and just simulating them at a larger
scale so that it felt slower even though
it wasn't sore because I wasn't actually
slowing down the frame rate of the vdbs
I just simulated them at a bigger scale
and so
um what you see here this is two
different elements it is the main
explosion plus a dust explosion that
goes out yeah I knew I wanted that that
pretty powerful impact and I started to
animate the the robots were going to be
getting smashed I really want a good
impact there and I added uh the fire
that's on the ground after the explosion
that's like a Niagara simple particle
system for fire nothing super fancy
there
um all the animations outside of the
boss are just miximo uh animations that
are tweaked and retargeted over which as
you mentioned retargeting is lots of fun
ah but it's the worst man it's it really
is the worst so like the worst you're
basically you have your like t-pose
characters your robot your hero
um and you grab essentially like the
animated skeleton from miximo you bring
that into unreal and pairing them is
just yes how did you you know you work
past that like how did you just YouTube
yeah so actually yeah yeah so actually
um unreal actually simplifies it a
little bit because most characters for
unreal especially if you buy them on the
marketplace they're all with the same
rig the Epic skeleton rig um there is a
couple of them they're like version four
and version five but for the most part
they're they're the same rig so uh
miximo there's actually a plug-in for
unreal to convert miximo animations to
Unreal uh epic skeleton within just a
couple clicks it's actually makes it a
lot easier
um do you remember to look it up I I'll
have to I I can I can drop a link or
something but it's uh
I forget exactly what it's called but if
you search the marketplace it's paid I
want to say it's probably about 30 bucks
or so
uh worth it yes the hours that you spend
trying to not break something is is
incredible yeah okay thank you for that
lead so thank you Yep this was my next
step here I started to fine tune the
explosions a little bit so I used the
Niagara uh particle system to create
like some pyro streaks and
um some rough like Boulders that were
coming off and uh just I added some a
little bit of grass foliage to the
ground nothing crazy
yeah I I knew I wanted more of that
Michael Bay kind of yeah big explosion
kind of effect
um this has a little bit of a blank area
on this one uh I added I wanted to bring
in some Cloud bdb so I could get some
more depth and volumetrics and at this
point this is when I decided I'm gonna
turn this into like more of an invasion
because I didn't really know at first
Matt okay they're battling this boss but
why is he there what is happening so I
wanted to convey this Invasion that
these guys are coming the bad guys are
coming and these are their ships in the
background so I tried to kind of color
tone it with dark blacks and Grays and
all the light emissive from them would
be like an orange color and you can also
see I changed all the good guys to a
blue yep can you trim the clip by the
way or Loop just the video portion
it'll just be a little easier to to see
figure
sweet okay so you're trying to separate
the bad guys from the good guys yeah
yeah
um because obviously the the hero is a
humanoid character and a Sci-Fi suit and
all the other ones are robots so I
wanted to make sure that the robots were
getting separated from the boss since he
is definitely like more of a robot type
character yeah and I wanted to play with
the cloud vdbs this one the color was
off
um so after that I ended up moving on to
uh this stage here so uh going along
yeah going along the lines of like an
invasion I started to add these drop
pods uh which were part of like kit bash
3D I wanted to give them a little bit of
static light as if the these pods were
coming from the ship and kind of Crash
Landing and these guys were coming out
of these pods yeah
um I don't know if I have it in this one
yet so in the beginning of the shot um
the main ship in the background you can
see I added some pods like shooting down
from the ship
um change the clouds a little bit so
that you could see a little more of the
the actual ships in the background and
so forth where are you getting these
ships these are just assets that you
have that you're correct Vib clouds
correct yes so the ships are big medium
small uh oh yeah that makes them and
they make some incredible stuff um same
thing very you know they are expensive
couple hundred bucks but you can catch
them on sale for half off 70 off I have
the time and and the amount of time and
hours that I would spend trying to make
something like that
um it outweighs what it costs and I
understand that everybody has the money
for sure but um no but you're you're
basically that's why we're doing these
interviews and these chats is because
everyone has their own workflow and this
is a very unique workflow that a lot of
other people
um love doing as well they love the
asset workflow yeah myself included So
like
um I think what you're doing there is
you're trading like uh time for money
essentially or money correct correct um
and and I've actually explained it that
way in the Discord sometimes when we get
people and they they talk about oh
that's so expensive and it's like
expensive is relative it really depends
on your money like obviously 50 bucks
might be expensive for one person but
not for another person and I just type I
try to break it down to them in the way
of okay if I was to try to model that
ship and the amount of detail that that
ship has and that's just one asset in
the pack I said just that one ship I
asked that person how long would it take
you to make that like be optimist and
they might say I don't know 50 100 hours
and I said okay so let's say it's a
hundred hours and I spent a hundred
dollars on it I said is your time worth
more than a dollar an hour
that's how I like to break it down is
like I know my time is worth more than a
dollar a hour I have a wife I have kids
I want to be with them I don't want to
take that time doing that would I like
to learn that skill set you betcha I
someday I will you know but I think for
the type of artwork that I like to do
and the role that I want to eventually
have you know maybe get in the industry
I'd love to be an environment artist or
a previous person I just like building
these worlds these scenes these
atmosphere and like you said getting
bogged down with all the technical stuff
along the way
that can really just hinder that and you
don't make as much big time yeah big
time Big Time I Think We're very similar
I love creating environments it's my
favorite photo real environments that's
my favorite thing to do when it comes to
3D so
um it's really inspirational to see you
put this piece together so I gotta ask
like usually when I use unreal I'm using
it as like a place to finish
I I will bring in assets from that I
maybe either created in c4d like if I do
have to create a custom piece of of
something I'll create it in C40 and I'll
bring it over into unreal to then be
used to to in my final scene are you
bringing in anything that you created
custom outside of the Ember gen assets
are you bringing in anything
um from outside programs
um not really so
um I actually try to do as much as I can
in unreal
um I know some of the tools are are
limited but there is a there is a
modeling Suite inside of unreal nowadays
that you can use for pretty basic stuff
um I use
um you know there's lots of little
plugins and add-ons and you know my my
goal for epic is to eventually someday I
never have to leave unreal whether that
be the modeling or you know I can use it
for physics I can use it for simulations
I can use it
um compositing and actually compositing
yep there's layers there's I mean you
can do all your color grading their
sequencing there's all of that stuff in
unreal and even in the newer recent
release 5.3 uh they added a bunch of
skeletal mesh tools too so now you can
actually rig weight paint and everything
right inside of unreal so is it the best
tools and the best workflow probably not
I don't really know because I don't do
it but um you know for somebody like me
who doesn't who isn't locked into a
different workflow this is great for me
because this opens up a whole
opportunity of doing different things
so I want to ask like we your art looks
so good at this point like where are we
at are we on like you know week four
final render here what is this
no um so this point is probably
beginning of week two
um dude because yeah how are you looking
at this and being like
it's not done it needs a lot yeah like
what yeah so at this point you know I I
had added my drop pods and stuff like
that and I knew what I wanted to do was
um I wanted to have a little more
interaction with the environment from
the explosions and stuff so
um I ended up going into uh some Physics
so I added some props and I added this
Barrel here
um so I opened up a second a second
level inside of unreal and I put the
barrel there gave it some collisions and
I added basically what they call a bomb
node inside and started to simulate and
record the actual explosion so that way
I could get some a little more
interaction to I mean this is a big
explosion and nothing else seems to be
moving or interacting besides the
characters okay
um so that was my first attempt was
doing a a barrel explosion here and then
I wanted to add some more barrels and
also interact with the the barrier so I
you can see one of the barrels on the
right side is just all out of whack
because physics you know yeah and uh the
barrier I took in I used unreal's
fracture node and chaos
chaos system
to break a piece off of it I didn't even
know that yeah
and it's it's actually really simple
really easy it uses the same type of
bomb explosion but you just fracture the
element and finally I fixed some of the
barrels and stuff like that and so this
here was basically my final
and of course I would take little breaks
in between because I you know I would
listen to a lot of the community and
people on Discord and they'd be like oh
man you should have the barrel hit the
barrier instead that's what's breaking
it it's not the explosion the Barrel's
hitting it so I moved the barrel over I
corrected the other barrels and crates
that I have exploding on the right side
and I was able to use those and kind of
animate them I used like a drag node
like a resistance node to be able to
kind of slow those down to give it that
slow motion effect which really it
worked really well
um and so basically what you see now it
is the final version
um minus uh color grading
so do you have
oh beautiful
what are you using a color grade
um Adobe Premiere which is probably the
worst thing to do but um whatever it was
just it's what I have yeah and I would
love to learn other software like
DaVinci or something like that I know
it's kind of a better workflow that's
right uh yeah I just exported as um
as a exr sequence put in Adobe Premiere
due to did a little bit of lumetri color
on it and and this is kind of what class
the final result ended up being so
out of unreal like do you have your
unreal scene open by chance like I do uh
can we see what this looks like before
you hit render I'm assuming you're using
the movie render queue with like some
console variables to spice up stuff in t
aliasing
correct whatnot yeah um is this all
lumen
um so I actually I actually rendered on
path tracing oh nice um that looks
better yeah a lot of my artwork I tend
to do path racing which has some
limitations
um
actually do work they do work now um you
do you can get some layering issues
um with the volumetrics uh in path
tracing but uh the quality
I feel is much better because you get
closer towards a traditional render over
Lumen Lumen is great
um and and it's kind of magic what it
does especially in real time but it's
also very cheaty it tries to get away
with a lot of things that uh traditional
render like path racing it kind of Brute
Forces it and says no I'm gonna make it
look the best that I can it gets you
like 90 there and when you switch to
path tradition you're like oh snap this
looks Yep this looks better when you use
that 10 yeah
um but yeah I would love to see your
your scene if possible yeah it's opening
up right now I haven't this the scene
got incredibly uh large and heavy
um so if you guys have questions for
metatrox by the way I see we have one
hit me with at Punisher so I can see
them
um so this just at play is asking are
you working a full-time job or when he's
not working a nine to five just trying
to gauge time investment here no shade
I'm just truly amazed and jealous
um so yeah what's your time investment
on this stuff so
um the time investment on this is is
pretty it's not crazy like I said a lot
of it just because I use assets and it's
unreal
things move a lot faster than you might
expect
um
up until about the challenge period
um I was actually working a full-time
job I was a business owner
um and so that becomes more than a
full-time job I recently a few months
ago actually sold my portion of the
business
in hopes of pursuing this more often so
the sale of the business has given me
the financial opportunity to be able to
okay I want to focus on this now I've
always wanted to do this a quick little
backstory about myself like I'm almost
40 years old I started doing Graphics
design stuff in the late 90s
I remember using software called like
Bryce 3D poser 3D back in the late 90s
and I have
3D work from you know there to about the
early 2000s and I took a long break in
between I was still doing just 2D
Graphics design for you know brochures
and flyers for just general people and
stuff and businesses and then a couple
year uh about four or five years ago
it started to touch on 3D again I got
into some software called Adobe
Dimension
um and which is incredibly simple it's
like a v-ray renderer but no modeling no
nothing it's basically it's meant for
like uh product renders and so I got
into there and I started to use it to
make these scenes for uh the game Pub G
and so I was working on that game oh
good dude a chunk of my life that was
the stuff yeah I was playing it like
crazy and I started ripping the game
models and making fan art it was cool
because the fan art actually led into
working with them
um on some stuff which was really cool I
had I had some officially licensed merch
I had done some uh artwork for them and
stuff
um some of my stuff even actually was in
the game uh the mobile version of the
game for a while so it was pretty cool
and this is a great example of
someone uh which can happen for all of
us following their passion and just
doing what they love for fun and how it
will turn into opportunities so like you
kind of create your own future in that
sense
um correct that's incredible I love that
yeah and I was just having fun making
fan art and it led down that path
um so this here is the unreal uh scene
um I'm not gonna play because it chugs
like crazy but uh you can see these are
just you know these are the kit bash
elements that I just kind of put in the
scene just to kind of fill stuff out
um It's always important to me that I
put stuff behind the camera for
Reflections and proper lighting and
stuff
um that usually people are always like
you're not even gonna see it why do you
put that there well I'm not gonna get
crazy detailed um and of course with uh
unreal and like nanite and stuff you can
you can add a lot to your scene so I I
fully built out the scene as as well as
I could because I wanted up close Crazy
detail like this in the Rocks but I also
wanted to see an entire environment and
so those ships and everything off the
vdbs back there it's all like real
geometry real
um you know volumetric clouds and stuff
like that and there's the there's plenty
of stuff that you don't even see you
don't see these buildings at a place way
back these were kind of early on and I
just never really got rid of them so
wait wait go go go back up top down view
where did you get that like topology
that road is that is that like a Google
Maps thing that you brought in um this
is actually a Quick's Omega scans they
have what they call the large Tundra
yeah Jake yep gigantic Sandstone terrain
so it's meant for views like this
because if you get down in here it's
it's not super good you know what I mean
you wouldn't want to walk or drive on it
or something wait was this like the
distance is this originally like green
with like water on it this one's kind of
Sandy like a Dusty it's part of their
sand uh yeah Sandstone terrain yep
sleeper freaking sleep grasses that's
right yeah yeah
um and so yeah that was this was kind of
the full scene
um there's a lot of characters in the
background that I kind of added in I
wanted to add gunfire I wanted to add
all sorts of interaction you know
another pod coming in with another boss
coming into the scene you know you
unfortunately you don't really see a lot
of that stuff and I know sometimes you
shouldn't spend time on things that
you're not really gonna see but you had
the time dude you had the time yeah I
had the time unfortunately
um I I want to hit the chat here and and
they got some questions for you so I'm
gonna shotgun
a couple questions at you that's cool
absolutely
um okay let's see
the model the boss changed a bit
somewhere in the middle of your render
is that the variation that it came with
or did you add it at it yourself how'd
that go down
um I did that myself so let me actually
close down the real one here and I have
uh this here that I put together this is
a little breakdown of how it get bashed
on top of it
um so I knew since it was a free asset
anybody could use it right and um I
wanted to make sure that my boss at
least had some sort of separation from
anybody else that might come in and use
the asset for their boss submission so I
started with the main his name's Richter
from Paragon so I added him in and I
knew I wanted to use some elements so I
have like a couple kit bash kits of just
simple geometry that I added some metal
texture to
um
added some stuff to his arms I he had
these gears on him already and some of
the animations that come with him
actually move the gears and I was like I
really like that idea but I want to take
it up a level so I added some more like
better detailed gears to it and I used
the Niagara particle system
to basically add some Sparks as if it's
like it's got this motion uh you know
pretty heavily inspired by like
Transformers and stuff like that I
wanted a little more uh Decepticon kind
of feel I guess you would say
um I really like the lights and stuff
that he already had so I I wanted to
take it to the next level and add some
detail
um I ended up getting rid of the face
um I wasn't super big on the skin uh
material on him and the face it's cool
but I wanted to make it different so
yeah by adding some body armor to it
covered up some of the skin and then I
uh found a couple free models of like a
skull and a a skull looking metal helmet
and so I took that and I booleaned it
out myself and slapped the the skull
inside of it and that was what
eventually came became in his head which
I feel like looked a little more
menacing than okay terrifying yeah it's
so good
um I'm gonna throw a couple more at you
let's see if we can shot in these
um
let's see see what part of 3D do you
struggle with the most and want to
improve on
um
I would say for me like I I definitely
want to learn more of the the technical
side of doing stuff so that when there's
a point that I can't find an asset or or
a you know find something I can make it
because ultimately that's the real
freedom is that like you mentioned
Jersey or with manual like it's kind of
this freedom to be able to make anything
you want yeah but working in an asset
pipeline like I do you don't always have
that freedom you're kind of restricted
to what you can find or what you can
afford
um and so that does make a difference
for sure I would like to I'd like to
know a little more modeling
and uh definitely
um texturing and materials
um I'm super excited uh thank you for
obviously getting me into fourth place
that that did give me the opportunity to
get a an ember gen license and I'm
really excited to jump more into there
and start doing some simulations and
stuff heck yeah man thank you so much
for taking the time with us uh we're all
blown away by your art and uh you're
truly an inspiration man I I keep going
with the weekly challenges I know you
just submitted uh recently so can't wait
to see it
um next week is going to be a fun one
too that I was telling you about earlier
so yeah it'll be fun as well very
exciting um
but Stephen thank you thank you so much
I'm glad that we were able to like make
a nice connection here I can't wait to
keep chatting and keep each other posted
on stuff man so
um yeah thank you for sure
so uh last thing before we bounce
anything you want to say to uh to the
artists out there watching
um just I would say get into the Discord
like join a get some ideas
um just even if you don't say anything
you don't talk just hop in get
inspiration from people there's always
people in there streaming and doing
stuff lots of different types of artwork
um don't become annoying but uh you know
like get in ask questions and stuff like
that
um and and do the weekly challenges it's
a great way to to keep fresh and try
something learn something new even if
you're not winning like obviously
everybody wants to win or get up there
but even if you're not winning just just
keep at it it's well worth it I'm kind
of late to the late to the game but you
can still do it 100 man 100 thank you so
much metatronics I'll see you on the
server and until then appreciate it okay
I'll catch you soon man take it easy
peace peace out
man
so good so good thank you guys for for
uh catching that one uh like I said you
know each artist has their own unique
workflow and I love seeing it happen
before our very eyes it's the best this
is like I freaking love these streams we
can keep it going and we're keeping it
going because that was only the third
artist we're talking to we got two more
our next one
um is Mr koala from China and uh koala
could not join us today
um
and he too
put out an incredible breakdown it's
wacky it's wild it's super funny it is
all over the place
um so without further Ado guys let's get
into our second place breakdown from Mr
koala let's do it
hey you guys this is koala I live in
Chengdu of China
I'd like make some stuff in blender
and you can follow me on Twitter
today I'll show my process about my work
in the boss fight challenge okay let's
do it
this is my first time participating This
Global challenge winning second place is
also a huge encouragement to me
I once participated in the Chinese
Community Challenge and I won the
championship you can take a look
but I want to try to compete with 3D
artists from all over the world in a
game this may make me grow and the
process will be interesting this month I
am challenging you
I'm casual person if I encounter a
difficulty that I can't overcome I will
go around it but there is only one
difficulty that I can't overcome that
it's the time how can I make a shot that
the audience can perceive in a limited
time
I don't know what the judges like but I
know what I'm good at and what I'm not
good at
so just be myself
my final idea came from the movies of
Stephen Chow who's my favorite actor I
had searching for some interesting ideas
from his movies in my mind
that's it
then I chose a rendering style based on
a cartoon I really like techcon concrete
I chose a boy I made his shape is very
simple but he's cool and expressive next
I just need a simple plot device to make
the characters relate to each other as
of now I have no idea what my boss looks
like maybe it's not that important the
boss attacks The Boy The Boy needs to
save one of them he makes a choice and
then he makes another Choice what an
amazing idea I drew the storyboard in
the shop file using the blender grease
pencil tools
I made the most basic pose without any
transition between keyframes this makes
the animation very clear
next I added some transition animations
be careful
don't let the transition animation blur
your keep holes
I did the stick effects and cloth
simulation
it's all fate I don't know how to
simulate the stick effects but I know
what the effect I need looks like so I
use modifiers in blender to create it
displacement modifier is forever a God I
made the other two characters relatively
simply because I knew their proportion
in the video would be very small and
they wouldn't take up a few pixels
something's wrong there's still a boss
left here why should I participate in
this competition this is too tiring
so I chose the previous koala robot he
once helped me win a championship in the
Chinese Community he might bring me good
luck in the past when I was doing it I
quickly sculpted its shaped ins brush
again and again again and again it is
very quickly and intuitively
but the final model I did it by hand
which was too tiring from that moment on
I knew I didn't like hard surface
modeling at all no matter what I finally
have a ball
[Music]
the texture Style
does not match
I had to repaint the texture in 3D coat
I wanted a rough hand painted look just
by hand
finally all the actors in the place
attention actors
everyone goes to perform with the boy he
is the main
then I added some shaking and
deformation details which made my
animation very exaggerated
I like exaggerated things
this is the charm of Animation just use
blender's shape key function character
animation is complete I can focus on
building and lighting I use lots of box
to lay out the composition of the scene
I think the modeling and details of the
scene are not that important I set the
main light to backlight it determines
everything the light in the far place
and the Darkness nearby everything is
for the silhouette of the character to
be clear some fill lights are only a
slight modification
finally it's the painful moment
how do I create the fire and smoke
effects I can choose to use displacement
to fake it or use real life video
footage but none of them met my
expectations
but I suddenly thought of a way I can
use Da Vinci to convert realistic videos
into stylized I'm such a genius
I will extract some characteristics of
hand-drawn effects from 2D animations
flattening sharpening edges reducing
details and extracting frames
then I use DaVinci filters to express
the corresponding characteristics the
effect is actually pretty good I
imported them into blender to match the
timing of the animation and regraded the
colors
I discovered the magical effect of
shockwaves by accident
thanks motion blur
next I need to make the buildings and
props I know their role in the scene
just as background film
I guess I don't have the energy to
create very detailed scenes so let's
turn on the magic the mid-journey
I generated some front facing images of
buildings and props and I put them
together into a 4K texture which is what
I often do to save Computer Resources
next I used a lot of boxes to piece
together the shape of the building and
projected the front inside of uv's
artificial intelligence technology hates
the job of UVS just like human beings
drawn some textures and added some
Chinese characters which may impress my
compatriots more
I basically got all the assets I wanted
I added the animation of the scene and
props directly to the model
these animations are very subtle but
what the character animation as a
reference they don't require too much
consideration
I only need to pay attention to the key
triggering time and some shaking
I rigged some spotlights on the koala
robot
the composition is a point worth noting
I have to keep the shape of the
character clear all times
the perspective of the buildings is all
fake the buildings in the distance are
directly shrunk and hidden in the file
I can't let the key points I want to
express be overwhelmed by the details of
a scene
I made the ground in buildings nearby as
dark as possible they were just a stage
shape that supported the actor's
performance
finally I rendered it
only your GB no depth compositing I use
DaVinci to adjust the color and glow
the koala robot is old and the other
work took me a week
I feel like I'm gonna stop working even
if it's not perfect because I'm so tired
I feel that I am limited by my creative
state and I cannot feel the aesthetic
when I am too tired my passion has also
been exhausted so I submitted
when I recall the process of this matter
I don't seem to have a very clear plan
but I will just start doing it
if there are technical obstacles I will
change the method but I think I still
achieve my goal to conquer more people
just in five seconds
some artists are interested in this
challenge but may not have enough time
in my opinion my koala robot has done a
great job but it was never prepared for
this challenge I never stopped creating
short animations if I had an idea in my
head I would do it right away without
any purpose
these exercises improve my skills and
experience and the challenge is just an
opportunity it will check your
accumulated results in one month I am
just like you I have many shortcomings
and I envy many artists who have better
Technical and artistic abilities than me
they inspire me but I think I also have
characteristics that other artists don't
have I am impatient but I'm strong in
action I'm not strict but I am humorous
I am not persistent but I am adaptable I
am not good at speaking English but I'm
good at Chinese you can also find your
own strengths our work is a composite
reflection of ourselves that's all
thanks Clint for your efforts thank you
everyone who's watching and thank you to
all the artists who have been creating
that's it
all voices are AI generated because I'm
not good at speaking English goodbye
dude that was that was like the most off
the rails breakdown that I had ever seen
yeah that was like it was it was just
like hopped up on energy drinks and off
the wall
um I love it I think part of it was
because of like the the dude's sense of
humor and also the AI generated like
voice that he had and his art going
throughout was just so wacky what a
unique style I'm I'm so inspired by by
that I freaking love it also
huge Stephen shop fan he is probably one
of my favorite directors no he is one of
my favorite directors of all time I love
his movies so much and inspires my sense
of humor my comedy my directing style
all that like Stephen Chow number one
um and Tech on King Cree is also an
incredible anime as well I got the art
book down here all the drawings by it
it's just super inspirational so thank
you koala sad that you weren't able to
join us this time around but man thank
you for that breakdown that was a treat
that was very special guys so we um we
got one more artist to hop into Mr
Fabricio the first place winner the
two-time first place uh Champion
um before we hop into that one uh little
announcement for you guys so
next week I have a video coming out it
is a photo scanning related video and uh
we're gonna we're basically we're gonna
be doing a scavenger hunt together all
right so that comes out next Saturday
October 7th and that's going to tie
directly into the Discord weekly
challenge so if you guys aren't a part
of the Discord server go down below
click that link hop on in it's really
fun and we're gonna do a scavenger hunt
together next week all right it's gonna
be a week-long thing it's gonna be super
fun uh you'll learn a ton it's gonna be
great
all right but I think now is the time to
meet Mr Fabricio let's do it let's hop
in
hey Fabricio what's up dude hey what's
up man how are you oh Do you have a
do you have the kashasa
yeah I am here with me ready for action
what you what you brought me at Camp
here so I'm gonna I'm gonna open up one
of these things so what what is kashasa
tell us what is kashasa you're from
ryoya
is a very traditional drink here uh
actually it is not another pure kashasa
it is a liquor made with kashasa uh who
knows the city parachi from in the
border of Rio De Janeiro Sao Paulo
nowhere I'm talking about there is a
festival over there there was I brought
my
my back off little kashasa drinks also
presented with a few
and also uh a few friends in the camp as
well uh who helped me a lot over there
yeah let's uh let's enjoy let's enjoy
this drink cheers yeah cheers man
um and let's pull up some images from
Camp so for the for those of you who
don't know Fabricio won the
endless endless engines Challenge and as
part of that challenge
um
he got a ticket to campograph so so if
you want to switch over
um to these images here we got some
pictures together we had a good old time
we were chilling
um so that's uh Fabricio on the left of
course and uh Sam the fifth place winner
um of endless engines on the right and
we're just hanging out having a good
time I got their stickers in each one of
my hands amazing
um we went on a hike together it was the
most wholesome time y'all
um
freaking the best the absolute best This
Is Us at bingo night
um that's David uh mellow mograph on the
right he won I believe fourth place in
Endless engine so this is
fifth fourth and first place endless
engines in the flesh together at Camp
mograph just the best time the freaking
best time we got a little Polaroid and
everything just Good Vibes all around
there's Billy so Billy in the middle he
was the first render of the top 100 like
the car on the city street at night this
is all of us just chilling having a good
oh
wholesome
time guys it doesn't get more wholesome
than that
so uh yeah yeah I agree we can switch
back now Soto but uh yeah
very good times
ah so good so so good yeah Fabricio I'm
I'm really amped to uh
to be here with you to be chilling
congrats on first place again uh how
does it feel to be a two-time a two-time
champ that's crazy yeah it is crazy uh I
can't be thankful enough and I thank you
so much I'm so so thankful it is so
humbling yeah it is amazing uh you guys
choosing me again for first place is
mind-blowing
I I don't I don't know what else to say
it is just my boy yeah man and like I
didn't tell
I didn't tell the judge that you had won
before
um so we try and go no biases of course
and you know it was both of our wins
both of our first first places and RAF
crossetti also from Brazil didn't know
you were from Brazil either and he was
like well I had nothing to do with this
guys look this is unbiased completely
unbien
um I thought that was funny
but um yeah man your art is incredible
um it was so great to meet you at Camp
let's let's get into the art man like I
didn't not know that this was Unreal
Engine first off is the most insane
thing
um
we'll get to it we'll get to that how
did you come up with this idea what
what's going through your brain to to
pull off this kind of thing
wow uh first of all uh I wasn't sure if
I would join in this challenge or not uh
I just finished one project uh in my my
daily work and yeah I have a uh a gap on
production so yeah oh why not and I have
this character I started producing it
was a personal Project based on a
friend's concept art uh years ago about
10 10 or so years ago
I started modeling it I'll show here
um yeah I started modeling this guy this
is the concept there is no concept art
uh but at the time I didn't have I I
didn't think I have this skill to finish
so I wasn't satisfied with the results
and I just dropped the project when you
make the announcement of boss fight the
first thing that came to my mind is was
this guy so oh man this is the chance I
have to I have to
yeah I have to back finding my backup uh
old HD or somewhere
and let's keep doing this and this is my
my was my starting point and uh I was
also at the time playing a lot of Final
Fantasy 16 which has amazing boss battle
sequences one of the most epic
sequence I I've seen a video game in
recent days and I
kind of started to connect the dots wow
man I have this guy it is a uh it is it
will be a good
Head Start yeah and yeah I want to do
something yet I'm not sure if they're
gonna make it but yeah I'll try that's
my try so so you start from there
I want to say that
um this kind of ties into everything
we've been talking about especially with
metatrox about him doing the weekly
challenges
um every single week and he's just
honing his craft more and more and more
all the time right
um in this case what you did is you had
your 10 your past self
help out your future self because you
were because you persisted in your 3D
Hobby and passion and now career you do
this as a job yeah right so yeah yeah
I'm full time for the others so
it like the things you do in the past
help you in the future and I just love
to see that definitely yeah that that
bring true here
um so yeah what do you do like how how
did you how did you uh mine this this
amazing model and bring it to a V2 how
do you finish it out where do you go
from here
uh well uh first of all I gather my
previous model and was really messy at
the time like like I said well it was a
more than a 10 years Gap I fortunately
developed my excuse in modeling uh and
also uh just before I jump into zbrush I
would like to show off also this guy
here my my best
my uh formation the best also helped me
with this one uh this is another amazing
concept I I made a work on top of it uh
many years ago as well so this was my
hero and uh yeah I keep kept uh
connecting the dots to make this
animation for boss fight
uh so
um after having my base mesh
ready yeah uh I
um I I I just said the UVS and jump to
the brush and started making a nice uh
from the top of my head I started
sculpting other details as well and kept
improving the model
uh not all pieces because it is too time
consuming but I think uh when when I
took actually the first step I took when
I
I picked the original model I jumped to
blender to make the block out
so I can show you this in the in the
second but uh yeah it was basically it I
just kept working in details
this one was already uh UV ready so I
didn't have to make jumping fourth uh it
is not so recommended because sometimes
you can deform this a little bit but I
wasn't too concerned with that so that
I'm fine uh and this so you can see
before uh when I since I didn't rely too
much in the brush I made things in Hand
by hand modeling each thing is it it is
so time consuming and now I prefer to
Scopes uh from a very base mesh and it's
way faster
yeah it is way faster and depending on
yeah this is one example but uh I detail
on top a very low mesh and uh well
depending on who you're doing you can uh
optimize this match and make a real
topology and take the details on top of
it but uh since I uh since at the
beginning I was aware that I was using
Unreal and using the advantage of nanite
meshes I just optimized the mesh and
send it directly to Unreal so I didn't
have to re read topology anything bake
anything I just the way it is here I
sent to Unreal and this works it's
awesome so you did all the detail here
um you took your pass model brought it
in a zbrush detailed it out and you just
focused on the Torso and um because
doing the legs was not necessary uh was
that a decision that you made
later like you originally wanted to have
the full body
um but realized it would take too much
time so you said let's adjust the idea
let's have it be the Torso
yeah actually it was exactly the first
option I never wanted to make the full
body character because in the past when
I was doing it took so long uh I don't
know maybe one more for more to make to
get that results that I wasn't happy
with it so yeah uh that definitely was a
No-No for me so uh I I made this
blocking in blender so right in the
beginning I was
it was very clear in my mind of what I
wanted to achieve but uh I always start
just
to work with the least elements possible
so yeah torso I also play a little bit
of the scale of the character I think in
the beginning was too big and was
covering all the background and yeah I
have to find this balance fine tune this
balance but uh basically it was the
tours of the character
right here I have two improviser arm
because the arm I I read it from scratch
I didn't have actually this was made in
the second day of the challenge
you had your direction yeah yeah yeah
yeah I kind of I have to I I went with
the first idea that came to my mind
because the first thing I I thought was
this character so yeah I had to do
something with this guy I don't know
exactly what it would be so first of all
I thought in making him hitting the wall
and the the hero jumping to save his
life that's what that's what it but then
well it is a boss fight right uh I have
to make something else uh maybe it she
counters the attack somehow and then I
thought about this this spear this
little spear here
but uh since I wanted to emphasize this
slow motion I just left hanging there
doing nothing and then I showed this my
wife and uh well what do you think and
she said it is boring really it's
important yeah and yeah and and she why
don't despair Heats him yeah because
he's too far away actually I'm using the
mid distance uh template yeah middle
using different yeah so he's really far
away so the spirit had to go away really
fast to hit him and in three or four
seconds I don't know how to achieve this
well I I really like the idea so I will
try to solve this I want to jump to
unreal I will show how I tackle this
issue sure sure actually it was a it was
a huge issue I think the most difficult
part of the whole project was to get
this uh spear from uh get right it was
the most like the motion of it or
finding a way to connect affect the hero
and the boss
ever everything related to this
spiritual the animation the connection
everything was uh the biggest challenge
in this whole animation but was very
nice
to try to find and try to solve this I I
it was my
a challenge between the challenge right
and uh sure yeah I really liked it to
surpass the
difficulties so once you have your block
out on day two yeah which is incredible
um a lot of artists it takes a lot of
time I know Edge is uh another very
talented artist on the server he takes
like a week to find out his idea
um you know so again different artists
different workflows right so you have
this on day two where do you go from
here
yeah uh well I
started I kept fine tuning a little bit
in blender uh to have the feeling
actually I
first of all I was just trying to block
it out it I wasn't making any lighting
blender because I I was since the
beginning I was planning using Unreal
but yeah why not since I'm in Berlin
they're building it so fast as well I so
I tried to test the light and it gives
me even a better idea of what what I
wanted to achieve so this is the second
working progress this was in unreal
already and uh I started animating a
very rough animation of this character
because I I I did I did this I took the
basement the whole base mesh
sent to mixamo make it a very
simple bones I can show it here for the
hero
yeah actually for both I I use the same
technique for both I sent to mix ammo
made the bones and uh I would love to
remember the name of the artist but
desires he make it available in art
station a free Contour rig Forum Rio
using mixed animal bones so it was just
one clicking you have your control
control Rigs and you can animate it
inside on Rio and also complementing
what meta tracks had said before and
really skip the keeps developing tools
so you don't need to go back and forth
between softwares and animation is one
of them I I was blown away how easy was
animated inside unreal
and if you have that
plug-in if you can remember that plug-in
maybe later yeah I've seen the link yeah
yeah I'll put it in the description of
this video along with metatrox's
um uh uh what is it um
retargeting situation he had that as
well so I'll I'll try and get both of
those links drops in the description but
okay so you figured out I guess
animation was your next thing yeah is
trying to lock that in for both the hero
and the boss try to get a sense of the
the motion of this yeah
yeah definitely so I I have the reading
the the rig ready so I can tweak the
animation and I went back and forth of
course here was a very big the base
model that wasn't the theory yet I would
I want to make sure if the animation
will work before I jump into the Tails
of the character of both of them
actually the hero I didn't do too much
in details because uh this model was
ready already but it was also the only
the tour so I have to build the legs as
well but I just uh reuse arm the arm
pieces to make the the leg works and so
uh wasn't wasn't a challenge at all uh
so the most challenging thing was to
make the the boss to work
um I did some motion captures using my
brand new Roku suit that I want amazing
challenge yeah I I kept connecting the
dots of why not I had this amazing
Hardware here uh it was in my side oh I
can I can show in the video because then
I'm sorry but uh yeah I saw that chance
of using this tool and what why not and
uh I have it
right here me trying to make the
animation of the the boss
you're cutting it close there that's
yeah and this is my wife
and uh oh amazing my dog helping
uh yeah and we she kept you jumping a
lot and was great for reference and of
course I took one motion one of the
emotions and was pretty gross what what
was in my what I have in mind before
and yeah I kept it from that she's this
is the motion capture I already started
to working a little bit on top of the
motion capture because it is impossible
to predict the arc the position they
will have to be on camera so I had to do
a lot of tweakings on top of the motion
capture so use that the Rococo motion
capture file that skeleton you yeah
paired it with this hero character and
then you adjusted the mocap detail in
unreal with this control rig yeah
yeah definitely it is great because uh
if I do this last year I will probably
go to blender or 3ds Max and do all this
motion capture uh clean up in the
program and support it with alembic
files or something like that and it is a
little more time consuming
um I I did this for the simulation here
or this wall breaking here I simulated
in 3ds Max
and exported you on Rio uh use the
Olympic but it is geometry geometry
cache is a little slow I when I jump to
one we will see
um I I could I could have done this in
unreal but I never worked before with
simulation I was just looking at the
metatrux workflow that would be so
helpful if I do this in an area but I
don't have the experience here I wasn't
sure if I should do or not so I prefer
to go I'm taking too much risks already
so I want to do something that I already
know how to use it yeah it has to be
manageable you know because it is the
project is just Challenge and learning
new stuff the whole way through like you
have to work to your strengths but also
keep in mind that you know let's try it
definitely at the same time
um so it's probably smart did that in
3DS
um so once you have this like what's
what's your next step you know I'm
loving this process so far yeah yeah uh
well I I kept it building the
environment uh and I went back and forth
during the environment building the uh
details of the character uh setting up
the lighting uh I can move a little
further here I'll have a more
developed environment as well and for
the environment I use basically the kit
Bash
this back here the medieval Siege yes
yeah
the environment is basically it so it is
amazing pack uh I didn't use any Mega
scan here but yeah it was worked so well
and yeah let's keep keep doing this well
I think you're lighting real quick I
just say your lighting is incredible
like how long did it take to work in
this lighting
um also you have these particles in this
fire are you using bdbs for that or is
that cards
yeah well I've jumped you unreal uh
since like I said before the geometric
hash is pretty slow with this uh
destruction here I will turn this off
and now yeah it is real time again
and yeah for the lighting
in here there is a lot of
shooting here
a lot of
this light over there I faked a lot of
stuff
uh but I I can break down the light in
four steps it was uh the environment the
environment
your moonlight
for those of you guys who don't know
Ultra Dynamics guys probably my favorite
plug-in for unreal um for lighting your
environment it allows you to control the
Sun the moon even stars
um down to like the fall it makes
everything so easy the fog all that
stuff
um it's like 40 bucks but it is so worth
it um it's my number one plug-in I would
I would use that so all right you got
Ultra Dynamic sky going with the Stars
the moon the clouds good stuff
um well definitely
yeah uh I started working for the fire
dude right there
yeah and uh a lot of volumetric lights
uh like here's the main the main one and
man it is so amazing working in a rear
because you can see everything is
working at the same time USU developing
the scene you're going to have a very
small stuff very simple very basic it
already working you can see the
the Shadows projecting through the smoke
and stuff like that that you could only
see after rendering pumping Etc it is a
long time that you are skipping just
using these two it is amazing yeah and I
can't stress this enough
and uh yeah I make the base lighting
here for the fire this is the main light
is it the biggest block of flight and I
start uh adding more like in the back
for example has a a small spot that can
make it like a ring light around the
in some places here because since the
beginning I'm very aware of the
Clarity of the information here the
points the composition that's why I
always start simple and start viewing a
building up on top of it because if you
start to putting too much stuff in the
very beginning and kind of lose the
controls of the what is really important
so I have this hierarchy of attention in
my mind it's the first thing that should
be seen is the boss so the main light
will hit the boss the boss has to be the
first thing actually I'm sorry I go back
again a little bit the the boss is the
first thing I want the audience the
audience to look at and uh I I have this
in mind so I I keep focusing the lights
all to the boss and whatever with the
environment and stuff like that
secondary so I work on that later uh so
having the fire set up I started working
with the moonlight
so give this mood and make some contrast
between the boys and the rest of the
scene
and because the boss is the only thing
that is uh orange and warm like evil red
stuff like that uh so the moon the
Moonlight this I started placing this
very nice automatic Spotlight here
and to balance the fire illumination
and and also it is so it is so fun to
work with Lighting in unreal because uh
you start having ideas in the middle of
the process like for example uh making
their lights helps tell the story uh in
the beginning the boss is all red but it
is hit by the the light of the fire and
when he is hit he gets hit when he has
moved back he the head the face is
facing the moonlight so it's not red
anymore change the lights like he was
defeated so it pulls down the light on
the on the face these are one thing that
I when I saw wow this is I think this
will work and I started developing on
top of this it was the position on the
head so it can face more of the light of
the Moon as well uh to think for this to
work a little more uh noticeable
um
what else uh yeah I did
extra lights as well
to help with highlight stuff highlight a
little details because the hero was just
a silhouette I just want to push a
little bit of the details as well
there's also these guys here that's
running for their lives and I I really
didn't want then be it's more like an
Easter egg it doesn't need to be
noticeable but I just want to add a
little that day over there so I place a
few lights just to highlight a little
bit each of them
so well done yeah the lighting is just
looking so so good
um yeah so you're basically just trying
to
um
reveal their silhouette and their shapes
uh as clearly as possible
um yeah like those little detail lights
that you did in the final step helps
with all that stuff
um it's yeah it's genius it's so yeah
well executed oh my God also got a shout
out wind Bush I see you in here mellow I
see you in here as well
thank you I can't yeah now I have the
chance to think thinking live because I
thank you so much for the tutorials man
helping me so much with this project
what's up man it helps us all he helps
us all for sure yeah yeah definitely uh
speaking of lighting uh one another
thing that I would like to highlight
because one of the most important
elements here was the hero spear it is
so small and I I kept thinking how I can
make it noticeable and I still I make a
lot of shooting uh make this happen
because I have this uh camera rail here
to follow the spear and also I think
this spot
so we can always follow the spear oh
nice
and yeah uh when let me just turn these
guys off
yeah if we turn off it helps a lot of
putting a lot of highlights over here
and also I thought it would be nice uh I
I have this this point slide here only
for making it Glow uh the spear glows in
a certain point like I think it is here
when you render it uh the post process
stuff made it catches a little more
noticeable yeah definitely yeah it reads
really well
wasn't thing and another thing that I
really wanted to make to make this
really works was making the I connected
um particle generation on the bottom of
the spear so it makes the trail
now that's really that's really great
the particle generation as well as the
trail behind it it really makes the path
of it readable
um and very very clear as to what's
going on
which is crucial with something like
this you don't want to miss that detail
yeah it is so small so I wasn't I wanted
to make sure there is in the very center
of the composition the spear because
yeah uh well having this hierarchy of uh
of attention of the main things that you
have to notice in your mind you can work
on top of that of that to make sure
there is noticeable well the boss is
very big so it is noticeable I didn't
want to make too much details on it so
because he's so big right and uh having
too much small details over there might
be a little
um noisy maybe it puts a lot a lot of um
how can I say that distress yeah a lot
of yeah yeah thank you thank you so much
a distraction and uh and in the opposite
of that we have the hero that is just a
silhouette so I have to go back and
forth and working with uh this
environment stuff as well uh was very
helpful so I could occlude the boss a
little bit so don't show too much of the
Tails I never in every place you look
like for example in his arm in his chest
he lives a little dim down right uh the
fog is covering a little bit so you
don't see too much of him it was
intentional just for uh make the hero a
little more readable can you talk a bit
about can you show by chance like how
you animated the boss
sure well I have the level sequence here
is very very uh messed up so I I get out
of the way but uh I have this control
rigs here so the boss I didn't use the
Rococo animation uh I I use zero open
image for the bus just for reference
because since he's so big any small
change of position makes a huge
difference so I prefer you doing by hand
this one okay uh so yeah basically you
can it is totally animatable
um
at this controls here that comes from
the control rig pre-made control rig
that I mentioned before
and yeah you just keyframe it like in
any other software as well having this
controls here you can go back and forth
from from blender or from zbrush
whatever software you're using to make
the ball the models you go back to the
brush and everything works and for the
boss uh well this is one thing with
midnight uh for who doesn't know this
you can't animate nanite meshes in
unreal unless if it is linked to a bone
or something like that you can deform
you can't deform nanite meshes so these
guys really heavy
uh in the geometry is very dense
I guess
and this came directly from the brush so
you'll see very small details here all
in the mesh
and at the same time it is totally
animatable because I
imported each piece separated converted
to nanite meshes and
parented to the Bone
the bonded that I previously generated
in XML can you talk about
your process for animating this guy like
specifically
um How do you
what do you start with do you start with
the Torso and then from the Torso you go
to the shoulders and the arms
and kind of work out from there and do
the head last
do you start with the key poses and then
do secondary after like how do how does
your process on that
yeah uh I make the key poses first of
all for expose the heating pose and the
after heat pose yeah
and started making keyframes in between
so I can hold more each pose and after
that I
um rearrange it um
let me see if I can do this really quick
um actually it's too messy sorry that's
fine yeah but uh basically uh I I have
the main poses and I start moving
keyframes so for example when it hits I
put some a little delay on the head I
started delay a little uh some movements
as well uh and then after having his
main animation uh ready of course I kept
tweaking this until the very end of the
the deadline so but uh in between I
started adding this uh extra animations
like
um this shoulder blades I also added
extra bones to make the controller to
control uh separated pieces of the armor
this one here
are you adding these bones and I'm real
no actually no uh I didn't blender uh
right I I think the last version of some
Rio you can add bones you can make
skinny in Reading uh since from from the
scratch inside unreal I didn't try this
yet I'm looking forward to it but yeah
uh when I was doing this project this
feature wasn't ready yet uh and I
make this secondary animations to
emphasize the impact of the the hit
and yeah it actually was very simple I
thought they would
take too too much more time than I
thought it would when I started doing
this one oh man I have to do the
secondary animation it'd be very hard to
make it no it is not it was very simple
to do it was harder in your mind
yeah definitely
that's yeah great that's great yeah and
and happens a lot right you start
thinking how how do I do this and
sometimes you think that you would be
way more work than you thought and other
things that would be more more simple
like this Pure Flow was definitely the
most difficult part of this brand
all right so tell me about the spear
throw why was it so difficult because to
me it just looks like a spline animated
along a spline that you drew and that's
that like what what was so difficult
about it
yeah uh well at first I tried to make
because you have to change the the
parenting of this control yeah so from
the hand to free like free controller
spline control
yeah at this point it should be linked
to the hand yeah and after this point it
should be linked to the uh to the camera
rail but the problem is uh doing this
switch it kind of messed up with the
motion blur so it keeps jumping the
jumping when make the switch of the
parenting I didn't know how to solve it
so I solved this probably there was way
possible that animation animating frame
by frame by hand so from here
uh it is good okay it is following the
radio but before here you can see there
is a a keyframe for each position of the
hand but it is continuing connected to
the radio since the beginning yeah
that's what's the best way I found it it
is not
uh yeah it is not very nice to do this
but since it was a very small chunk of
the animation that I should do this over
let's try no that works that works
that's probably what I would do
yeah
man okay all right so but it took you a
while to figure that out you were
troubleshooting that problem for days
ah four weeks oh my goodness yeah uh I
just solved this in the very end of the
of the animation of the deadline and
when did you submit how many days would
you submit on the last day second to
last day uh no I think was uh three or
four days before the deadline okay
that's healthy that's good that's very
good yeah I didn't want to go too crazy
for this when when did you know that
this was all complete like once you
finish the spear animation you're like
this is done my environment's done my
animation's done
um was there anything you added at the
very end that you were like you know
what it needs this it needs that
oh yeah I think this is the most
difficult Parts because uh I don't think
we we ever finish a project we have to
call it done because otherwise we won't
deliver so yeah I just followed well I
think it is good enough
uh there are a few things that I I would
probably continue working on like the
animation of her fluidity of the
movement some arcs uh maybe some some
stuff in the background but yeah uh
if I wouldn't submit probably I would
work in this animation too today so yeah
you could always find something to to to
tackle and to do it and it is an endless
process
yeah I remember reading something uh
somewhere at some point that there's
this thing that like
um you will essentially fill the time
you have with the task you need to do so
like if you have a three-day task
anybody you have a week to do it you're
probably gonna do that three-day task
over the week
um
yeah and I'm like you know that's a good
point I feel like especially for me I
I push everything to the last minute too
so I have to fight against my natural
like ability to just naturally go to the
last second
um yeah so yeah time management is tough
so how how are you yes managing your
time during this project are you working
on this eight hours a day are you
working this two hours a day like
what's your setup yeah it wasn't that it
wasn't very hard to manage because I was
in between projects uh in my actual work
so I have spare time to make this in
this project and have full attention of
it so yeah most of my time my time six
eight hours a day I was dedicated to
this project the rest of the day I was
chilling and resting and wow recharging
yeah uh was yeah it wasn't it wasn't
that hard uh actually
so yeah there was it wasn't too much
going on work wise in between
so what would you any advice that you
would give to people
who are watching this and wanting to
join the next one in February what would
you tell them oh just oh just try guys
because uh before
these challenges uh before the the last
year uh I was too busy to work on and uh
when I have a little time maybe to start
doing something for the challenges uh I
thought that oh did
the bar is so high right uh it is so
intimidating seeing so many amazing
works uh looking at the breakdown I was
just watching before uh before we're
talking here it is so amazing and it is
so easy to get intimidated by that but
the the worst thing that thing happens
is you learn with this experience even
if you don't get in top hundred
let's try if you have enough time of
course uh
there's no reason not to try
a great man 100 it's only fun yeah it's
only fun yeah good job definitely and
having the chance to talk to people and
uh and have this feedback with the
community as well it is so fun as well
it is so great to follow others as well
what they are doing talk to them it is a
great opportunity to do this so yeah
just try guys it is 100
um you guys have heard me shout this out
before but seriously hop on to the
Discord come join us come hang out um
ask Fabricio your questions ask all
metatrox your questions uh share your
art with us join the weekly challenges
um and dive in dive with dive in with us
it's gonna be good
um
it's very very fun so Fabricio is there
anything that you want to share like do
you want to play your whole sequence
that you made to to close it out perhaps
like you put together a whole short a
little short film
um yeah that would be fun I can also
show my
my da Vinci ah so good oh
and uh one one thing that is helps me a
lot uh to evaluate if the scene is
working or not is zooming out
pretty much oh let's see if you scare if
you can still understand it and also I
have this note here that I can just
a little animation
and it is so helpful because you keep
seeing this for weeks right you have
um
how to say this uh when you
don't see some details that we are
working so much on it and uh
you have your you have to have a fresh
uh fresh eyes sometimes right but that's
why it's always showing to the community
and close ones as well and this is one
one way that I can find that I can kind
of reset reset my perception of the job
and evaluate if it is working or not
that's a solid one yeah 100 percent
man it's beautiful
I love that you took the Bluetooth green
one with the green red
is that green I hope it's green hope I'm
saying the right thing I'm colorblind so
yeah yeah it is greenish yeah a little
bit good you were silent first I was
like oh crap
[Laughter]
play your your short film the final
short
oh yeah
um I'll pour one more uh kashasa
shot here awesome yeah I mean me too
I like the banana so far
oh awesome
I think cinnamon was a cinnamon
uh yes there is no cinnamon there wasn't
banana is the other one I think it was
coming I don't remember
coconut one's thick man it's like a
like a syrup
how do I
I wasn't prepared to show the extender
uh oh drop film but yeah I'll get there
yeah too here it comes but uh can I play
with audio
will stream the Audio I don't know
that's a sodomonte question
no just video
uh now he's saying maybe
all right just turn it up if we hear it
we hear it
well let me know if you can play
I just prepare
[Music]
so you did all this after obviously
right like I didn't in there last week
of the final week so you you were
soloing on top of your submission before
you even submitted
yeah uh
oh my soul is so loud
yeah go again go again go again
uh it was very fun because uh I enjoy so
much making this project I was kinda I
was kind of sad that it was finishing it
and I just wanted to do more and since I
I have already all the Assets in unreal
it was so fast to do this one I did all
the old animation in three days
jeez man
yeah oh and this animation here was the
actual motion capture from Rococo that I
showed before me suiting up with the
Rococo that that's me the hand animation
I didn't animate anything in this
animation
that's what's up man so yeah if you guys
want to follow Fabricio obviously you
see his socials there they're also Down
Below in the description
um if you want to follow any of the
artists here on the on the stream so far
um
but Fabricio man thank you thank you so
much thank you so much man thank you so
much for having me thank you so much for
these challenges everybody is involved
it's amazing it's a great opportunity
experience I can truly stress this
enough yeah truly man it was an honor to
meet you too at Camp
um yeah me too likewise maybe I'll come
down to Rio and hang out we'll see you
know we'll see maybe yeah
we do both ways yeah awesome man thank
you so much Fabricio I really thank you
so much man thank you so much everyone
I'll catch you soon peace out
very good stuff thank you guys so much
for uh for hanging out
for enjoying the art together learning
about the different workflows
um yeah these are always packed with
info so
like I was saying next week we have a
photo scanning challenge that's going to
be running for one week on the Discord
server I'm putting out a video October
7th you guys will watch the whole
process it's a it's a hoot it's a good
time uh an absolute blast and you guys
will have a week to uh gather some photo
scans
so definitely keep your eyes peeled for
that if you're not subscribed you know
what to do hit that subscribe button
down below the Bell hit the bell I don't
know if the Bell works I'm not good with
this stuff guys
um but uh but hang out y'all oh look at
that so it won't take you in the little
subscribe thing
oh good happy to have you man
um we're working on a project too I mean
sotomonte we're gonna do a little thing
for Halloween so that's gonna be fun I
look forward to that lots of good stuff
coming along
um I'll be doing to be doing another
um 3D Community challenge in February of
next year so if you guys want to
participate uh again subscribe to the
channels probably the best way join the
Discord if you're not already and uh
yeah stay tuned with us create some art
with us it'll be a good time
so I think guys that that's it we hit
our artists
um we got the announcements
um shout outs to It Rococo who sponsored
this whole thing
um go check out rikoko Vision linked
below it's like a no suit needed motion
capture two camera motion capture
solution
um so that'll definitely help you guys
out with your animation to get ahead of
the game
um and so the other sponsors to Jenga
effects who very generously allowed you
guys to use ambergen for free for the
month
um yeah incredible incredible kit bash
3D giving out awesome kits
um cargo subscriptions
um yeah absolutely absolutely
fantastic and caft of course guys giving
you all shirts top 100 shirts to the top
100 and uh codes to the winners guys so
thank you thank you so much if you guys
I'll hang out with you guys for like
five minutes or so if you have any
questions hit me up let's hang out for
just a little bit and then we'll call it
um and then I'm gonna get some food my
goodness I can't wait cannot wait
give me a good time
let's see do we have anything anything
else any other updates
um here's a little sneak peek to a video
coming out
in when is it coming out november-ish
this is your only this is your only
piece of
of context here is this right here
I'll just I'll just hold this here for a
second
Pokemon Yellow for the Game Boy Color
all right I'm doing a little thing
with some game boys and we'll get more
info on that as we get closer
but I'm very excited very very excited
um
hit me with the app Punisher here in the
chat if you guys have any questions
um about our artists about uh you know
Challenge questions videos in the future
just personal stuff I'm hanging out with
you for five minutes
thoughts on unreal five I'd say it's
about my favorite thing in 3D right now
the mo I get the most satisfaction out
of creating photoreal environments
inside of Unreal Engine 5. and for this
challenge for boss fight I
I went back to c4d
which I hadn't used in a minute to be
honest because I've used so much unreal
last year
um and I tried to tackle a new style uh
cartoony style has kind of effect and
um
I feel like doing this challenge was
very ambitious especially for hopping no
program I hadn't been using in a minute
and especially for like unearthing a new
style
um
so yeah I know I learned a lot during
that process
um and I think
I originally was like you know what
I want to try a new style
um and I think if I really wanted to do
that I should have bitten off something
a little bit smaller and that's always
my problem always biting off so much
um and I think tackling like you know
say for instance just modeling this in
in 3D and doing a stylized version of
this would have been a great way to test
the stylized workflow I just didn't have
it under my belt you know so I I didn't
make the deadline it's difficult but it
made me want to get back to Unreal and
like play to my strengths which is
photoreal environments I love it so so
much
um let's see guys let's take a look at
your questions uh I want this Auto rig
that Fabricio was using yes me too
um I'm gonna get that link for him
as soon as he drops it same for metatrox
he had that like um uh what's it called
always forget uh retargeting and auto
retargeting setup in unreal as well I'm
gonna get those links in the description
under resources tab
um so check out the video later uh let's
see
um
yeah elephant's show he says that was
your problem with the challenges you bit
off way more than you can chew
and had to submit something not great
but hey look that's okay you at least
you submitted you got to the point where
you could submit something and you
probably learned a lot along the way as
well and that's that's the most
important thing is learning something
along the way whether you submit or
don't submit
can you
think back on your experience
and get something out of it what can you
get out of the month you've spent
working on this art that you either
submitted then submit got into top 100
or not
got into the all renders or not whatever
you know
can you go back and kind of break down
your experience and see what you can
apply to the Future what are the things
that you learned along the way because I
think um
you know you've probably heard this said
a bunch before
but
um a failure not learned from is a true
failure
a failure learn from a failed experience
that you that you learn something from
is a win right
so how can you take maybe a failure in
your mind and turn it into a win and
obviously failure is very harsh an
intense wording but I think you guys get
the point right
um
dude modeling the Game Boy cartridge
with just displacement Maps that's
insane but also very possible
um yeah substance designer is ridiculous
it's not a 3D modeling software but uh
it can be used to create
uh yeah not just textures it's an
incredible one
do I know if studios are using ue5
currently I don't know I'm not sure like
I'm not tapped into the pulse of the
studios
um I'm sure they are yeah I'm sure they
are I do know
um I believe it is used in like a lot of
different like sports uh kind of live
sports setups I do know that that's
that's a thing
but beyond that I mean I'm sure I can't
say for a fact though
besides games obviously it's used in
video games one of my favorite games of
all time
stray it was made using Unreal Engine
and uh there's a great video on the
making of that game if you guys don't
know if stray is the cat game it's like
a seven hour campaign I beat the thing
three times it is probably one of my
favorite games in in recent years easily
um and they did the whole thing in
Unreal Engine and watching the breakdown
there's like a 15 minute little video on
YouTube about the making of the game and
it shows it talks about all the
different challenges that the studio is
just two people really at first it's
just two people it talks about all the
challenges they faced um and the things
that they had to overcome using Unreal
Engine
I'm like man I always get like amped
when I see the Unreal Engine logo on a
game I'm about to play I'm like wow this
is really inspiring like uh sifu that
game was Unreal Engine stray was Unreal
Engine a ton more of course but it's
always like that's the program I use
maybe I could do this you know it gives
me a lot of um inspiration seeing that
perfect anime don't you worry you missed
out on boss fight but it's okay
um
I don't know why maybe it's just you
weren't checking YouTube at the time
maybe the Bell thing doesn't work
because YouTube can be jacked up who
knows
um but yeah like I said
subscribe come by the channel often uh
hang out on the Discord you're on both
of those you shouldn't be able to miss
it but it's in February the next one's
in February that's why I try to tell you
guys ahead of time
dude that's so funny your grandma liked
the alternate reality challenge the most
she loves seeing what people did with
the round object in the corner could
challenges popularity benefit from
sticker templates
what I don't understand the last part
from well from stricter templates
I don't know maybe we always go back and
forth trying to figure out the templates
me and the moderators on the Discord
server
um we're like less strict more strict uh
characters no characters but we try and
do a different one every time we don't
want to put out the Same album
every album release we want it to be
different every time and reinvent every
time so that's the idea
but that's funny you said your grandma
because
my whole like the thing I always say is
that the all renders montages are like
more for the artists and I know I think
this also came from sotomote too the all
renders is like for the artists but the
top 100 is for the world
and like the way I see it is your
grandma should be able to enjoy the top
100 video anyone should be able to enjoy
the top 100 video and the all renders
which of course lots of people enjoy too
um but I know the artists get really
excited about that one as well
um but I'm glad your grandma likes it
say hello to your grandma for me I'm
glad that she enjoys the challenges
that's really fun
yeah
ah let's see
um
I'm curious to know if you do anything
else other than YouTube and 3D that you
spend your time on my goodness yes yes I
would go insane if I just spent my time
on YouTube in 3D yes this is my
full-time job this is what I do for a
living
oh let's run this YouTube channel and
host challenges and teach people about
art and whatnot and how to use programs
um but uh I'm writing a feature film
right now I've been writing it for a
while actually writing it with my wife
so we're working together to put this
this very very fun very silly movie
together directing is my passion I'm
doing all of the V effects all the 3D is
um for me
it's a way to just be better equipped as
a director and I fell in love with 3D
very early on I fell in love with 3D and
VFX
um before I wanted to make a movie
um it was just so much fun for me and it
was it was an immediate payoff
and it wasn't until a couple years into
doing the effects that I decided you
know I want to
justify these VFX I don't want these VFX
shots to just be VFX reels I want to do
VFX for
um I want I I want to see VFX serve a
purpose a greater purpose to tell a
larger story so then that's when I
started get to get into writing short
films
um shooting them doing the BF VFX for
them editing all that stuff right that's
where cardboard Warfare came from uh the
whole series that's where I started
doing
um like little uh short film maybe you'd
say fan film
um shorts for different video games like
Sleeping Dogs Kill Zone Wolfenstein a
lot of which were like official for the
game which was so cool
um that was back before I was a part of
Rocket Jump with Freddy before I was
even a part of corridor but all of those
people were there all of those people we
were all friends at the time and we were
communicating
um online just like you know we're
communicating on Discord server right
same idea and we'd be helping each other
out with different effects problems and
3D problems
um and showing each other our short
films and being like Oh you know like I
would do this here do this there and it
was all because of the community that
we all get so inspired so I think it's
cool that we still have this this
massive Community I can't believe
there's like 70
000 plus people on the Discord server
which is
saying I never would have thought for a
second that
like doing all this stuff would would
amount to that it was never my goal it
just kind of happened
it's pretty pretty nice Winbush shout
outs team man shout outs so wind Bush
you were in Korea this man was up in
Korea
um for part of some like 3D conference
and got to meet the the governor of
Seoul I believe and got these custom
like sake Soju glasses with his his face
and the governor's face like together
imprinted on to the onto the the Soju
bottle I was like dude that is so funny
I love it we missed it at Camp though
man we definitely missed you at camp
it was a good time
really really good time
Elven show so how's the feature film
coming along man it's hard it is
probably one of the hardest things I've
done in a minute
I'm so used to immediate payoff that's
why I love 3D so much
um and like that's why I love unreal so
much is you get that immediate payoff
with a short uh or with a feature film
writing a feature film is probably one
of the hardest things I've ever done
and it takes so much
persistence to keep moving forward
um because every day
isn't guaranteed to be a great day of
writing you have to really push through
the difficult days of writing
and doing something that's so difficult
you naturally like don't want to do it
right you don't want to wake up and just
be met with difficulty
but that's what it's requiring like it's
gonna be hard it's gonna be hard and it
has been hard but it's also been great
because we've made progress and um
like I'm going as far I'm doing whatever
I got to do to motivate myself to keep
going to keep the daily streak going
writing every day at 8am we write me and
my wife and it's like we'll go as far as
we got a sticker board going if we wrote
today we get a sticker and I want to see
that sticker board full at the end of
you know three months or whatever and
we'll start a whole new sticker board
and like I wish
life
had
stats video game stats how many miles
have I walked in my life how many hours
have I spent writing how many
um hours have I spent meditating
um like
I want to know my life stats I wish
there was something
that I could tap into that would show me
all my stats because I don't know it's
really inspiring to like look at all the
the stuff that you that you've put into
you know all the payoff
and um
yeah sometimes rambling at this point
but
life stats yeah the the film's going
great though
um we're making Daily Progress on it and
it's really fun it's super goofy I can't
wait to tell you guys about it
oh I want to tell you guys about it so
bad but I can't yet it's not ready
um I want to get to the point where I
can do a proof of concept film that
release it put up a Kickstarter and see
what we can do see what we can what we
can generate maybe get the help of some
studio to
help fund it too but having it be
crowdfunded self-made kind of thing with
the community would be
would be the dream
um
I think it would be I think it would be
incredible
it's gonna be a fun one the plan is to
walk you guys through the process of the
whole movie Once the movie gets to a
point where like
the ball is rolling into production I
want to be shooting videos on like how
do you write a movie how did I write my
first feature
um how would you produce a scene like
this how are you going to get resources
together to like do an action scene like
this
um and I want to cover all that stuff on
the channel right
um because for me filmmaking is the
passion and I want to include that on
the channel as well I'm sure a lot of
you guys could uh could benefit from
that as well so that's the goal
that's the goal
yep just hit play that's exactly what
I'm talking about
that's exactly what I'm talking about
um hitting all aspects of production the
writing the shooting the producing the
creating music for a movie like all that
I want to cover all of that and just be
able to be like here is how you can make
a movie yourself
go for it right
um
but yeah that's the idea oh so metatrox
looks like metatrox just hit me with
that retargeting plug-in
Fabricio hit me with the control rig
plug-in
that's what's up I'm gonna update these
um right after we call it I'm probably
gonna call it here guys
probably gonna call it
um
thank you guys for joining me I really
appreciate it
please please please keep your eyes
peeled for next week I got a really fun
photo scanning video that involves all
you guys we're gonna do a week-long
challenge it's gonna be really fun
um and I'll be out there with you
it's gonna be sweet so stay tuned y'all
stay tuned uh I I think I've talked
myself out guys I think that's
everything I'll see you on the Discord
I'll see you here next week on the
channel
thank you so much guys for joining we're
learning from all these artists I know I
learned a ton
um yeah keep going keep that spark alive
y'all I will catch you guys on the next
one
at some point
next week yeah see you next week later
guys peace out
[Music]
thank you
foreign